messieurs bonsoir et bienvenue à l'école
militaire bienvenue
également à tous les internautes qui
nous suivent en direct depuis les
chaînes youtube d econoclaste de signes
que review est la toute récente chaîne
youtube de l'école de guerre alors c'est
un grand plaisir pour nous d'accueillir
aujourd'hui les econoclastes pour ce
premier grand événement de l'école de
guerre le premier d'une future longue
série vous
savez vous devez savoir que l'école de
guerre forme les futurs grands chefs
militaires des armées françaises mais
aussi de plus de 60 pays partenaire et
ami de la france qui nous font confiance
et
c'est parce que ces futurs grands chefs
vont peser dans les choix de la nation
qu'il
cherche à s'ouvrir à toutes les grandes
problématiques stratégiques du monde
d'aujourd'hui ici
ouvre aux besoins de manière iconoclaste
leur but est de développer une pensée
stratégique aussi innovante que possible
qui leur permettra de faire face demain
aux défis qui ne manqueront pas de se
faire jour c'est
bien l'objet de cette conférence
préparer
l'avenir ou plutôt se préparer à faire
face et puis à résoudre demain des
problèmes qu'on ne connaît pas encore
aujourd'hui alors
pour sortir des sentiers battus
peut-être pour battre le fer d'idées
neuves nous
avons le plaisir d'accueillir
aujourd'hui trois conférenciers d
econoclaste olivier
delamarche tout d'abord que beaucoup
connaissent déjà bien
olivier est un ancien trader
fondateur de plusieurs sociétés
d'investissement financier conférencier
chroniqueur économique il aime sollicité
le débat a porté la contradiction kit
éventuellement à bousculer quelques
idées reçues visionnaire
pour certains incorrigible
cassandre pour d'autres son
franc-parler a fait de lui une
personnalité qui ne laisse pas
indifférent son
arme favorite l'analyse des chiffres à
la source pierre
sabatier à présent pierre
et fondateur d'un cabinet de recherche
économique et financière
chroniqueur également stratège en
finance de marché gérant de portefeuille
pédagogue reconnu par de nombreuses
grandes écoles il
est l'auteur je ne dirai pas son âge
mais il est l'auteur de cinq ouvrages ou
co auteur de cinq ouvrages et accompagne
déjà les dirigeants et les futurs hauts
potentiels de nombreux grands groupes il
a reçu en 2013 le prix turgot du jeune
talent en économie financière il fait
partie finalement comme les officiers de
l'école de guerre d'aujourd'hui de cette
génération qui prépare le monde de
demain nicolas
meilhan enfin nicolas est consultant
dans les domaines de l'énergie et du
transport il
travaille auprès des plus grandes
entreprises du secteur diplômé
du prestigieux et mighty il s'est
spécialisé dans la raréfaction des
ressources et dans la transition
énergétique
ils
analysent ces phénomènes et leurs
conséquences notamment sur la mobilité
du futur il travaille sans a priori sans
dogme sans tabou et surtout sans
pression extérieure finalement un peu à
la manière d econoclaste messieurs
nous sommes impatients d'entendre votre
analyse du jour d'après et c'est avec
grand plaisir que je cède la parole
bonsoir
à tous bonsoir merci amiral de nous
recevoir chez vous et
merci à a eu d'avoir organisé cette
conférence nous
allons commencer par un constat parce
que il faut bien analyser les faits
avant de de trouver des des solutions
est malheureusement un les faits sont
souvent pas têtus comme le dirait un no
econoclaste mais sont souvent maquiller
arranger emballé
de façon al voulait présenter d'une
d'une manière rose alors qu'ils ne sont
pas si rose que ça malgré le la première
image on va vous parler démographie
parce que je pense que c'est un des
problèmes qui est rarement adressé par
les politiques aujourd'hui et
par les économistes et qui
malheureusement est un problème central
qui
va jouer sur la croissance potentielle
des pays et qui va entraîner un certain
nombre de conséquences un plus ou moins
désastreuse et je vais commencer par
céder la parole à pierre qui est un
grand spécialiste de la de la
démographie on va faire un petit tour du
monde de ce qui se passe de ce qui va de
ce conte de ce vers quoi on va dans les
dents des années qu'ils sont pas
tellement éloigné il faut faire
attention on parle souvent dont donne
souvent des chiffres en 2050 2050 c'est
demain c'est
pas très éloignées et les conséquences
sont déjà maintenant maintenant sur la
croissance maintenant sur les flux
migratoires maintenant
sur un ensemble
process vous savez qu'aujourd'hui on
table sur des croissances alors tous les
ans on nous on essaie de nous endormir
en nous disant que l'année prochaine
sera meilleure que l'année dernière
c'est toujours un petit peu meilleure
que l'année dernière mais
malheureusement la
croissance les ce qu'elle est et elle
est contrainte par un certain nombre de
de fait il se trouve que malheureusement
quelqu'un qui a 65 ans à des revenus et
à des dépenses qui sont en général de la
moitié de ce qu'ils avaient au pic de
son de son
de sa de sa croissance bay était un
super formateur avant peut-être de
rentrer dans le détail pour qu'ils
comprennent bien en fait là où on veut
en venir en fait ce soir lorsqu on a
discuté voilà qu'est ce qu'on fait ce
qu'on veut sur quoi on veut insister en
fait dans le monde d'après parce que
vous nous demandez un exercice bien plus
passionnant d'ailleurs de ce qu'on nous
demande souvent dans les médias à savoir
pas ce qui va se passer demain après
demain ou le trimestre prochain mais
véritablement levé la tête et essayer de
voir loin pour essayer de déceler des
tendances qui ferait que ce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui n'est pas le fait du hasard
et nick et n'est pas non plus
conjoncturelle alors on a un peu fait
les médecins et donc on s'est interrogé
pourquoi finalement tout ce qu'on met en
place semble être un peu à côté de la
plaque je crois qu'il faut qu'on se
repose encore une fois la question du
constat parce que globalement lorsqu'on
est médecin si le diagnostic est mauvais
vous avez beau être le plus intelligent
de la terre connaît tous les traitements
du monde vous ne choisirez pas le bon
traitement et c'est bien là l'enjeu
aujourd'hui l'enjeu est ce qu'on voulait
c'est sûr qu'on voulait insister ce soir
c'est que probablement notre monde
d'aujourd'hui ne regardent pas au bon
endroit yark manque des choses montrées
à se focaliser sur des choses qui
peuvent être plus accessoire qui est
essentielle alors que le premier point
essentiel est ce qu a évoqué a évoqué
olivier c'est bien celui de notre
transformation nous sommes en train de
changer c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous concentrons nous constatons des
frictions pas que chez nous d'ailleurs
les frictions elles sont partout elles
sont aux etats unis elle songe à paul
sont en europe et elles sont bien sûr
aussi dans le pays les pays émergents on
y reviendra un peu plus tard la première
chose qu'on voulait vous montrer c'est
effectivement comprendre pourquoi on
vous parle de vieillissement souligne
olivier ni moi même si on aime cette
matière là nous sommes démographe mais
par contre c'est très important de
comprendre pourquoi nos sociétés
dépendent de notre pyramide des âges on
est venu vous montrer quelques images on
dit souvent méfiez vous des gens qui
parlent bien donc parfois les graphiques
par le mieux en fait qu'un long discours
aux dix plus de choses vous avez sous
les yeux en fait quelque chose
d'essentiel premièrement il faut savoir
que la richesse concret dans nos pays
quel que soit l'endroit du monde repose
sur vous sur votre propre consommation
sur les dépenses des ménages partout
dans le monde ça pèse à peu près deux
tiers de la richesse créée si vous
ajoutez à cela vaut comportement
d'investisseur vous particulier où nous
entrepreneurs concrètement vous avez
l'essentiel en ce qui veut dire quoi ce
que veut dire que la richesse concret
dans l'ensemble des pays notamment des
pays riches elle repose sur vous sur vos
comporte monde notamment vos
comportements de consommateurs et c'est
là où la démographie est intéressante
vous avez sous les yeux la photo d'un
français votre photo ici vous avez 25
ans est é si vous avez 80 ans et ça
c'est simplement ce courrier sous les
yeux c'est l'évolution de votre
consommation en fonction de votre âge
ici 45 55 à 65 ans etc et donc c'est
important d'avoir cela en tête parce que
si vous comprenez bien que la richesse
concret dépend de vos comportements à
vous aimez vous comprenez que cette
forme de consommation au fil de votre
âge va gérer modifier votre potentiel de
consommation donc le potentiel de
croissance demain la commande en deux
secondes pour vous dire que deux choses
intéressantes cette photographie qui
vise à vous montrer simplement vous
consommez de plus en plus entre 25 et 45
ans logique vous ou vos études vous
n'aviez pas de revenus vous êtes en
train de construire votre foyer il ya
toutes les raisons pour lesquelles la
vous avez vous devez en fait consommer
45 55 ans là vous êtes un super
consommateurs s'ils avouent consommer le
plus donc en fonction de votre âge de
manière à dégager mais aussi vous
comprenez très aisément vous avez acheté
votre première maison à 31 32 33 ans un
peu plus tard à paris parce que les prix
à limoux l'immobilier sans peut-être un
peu cher le bon grosso modo vous êtes
trentenaire vous achetez votre premier
bien immobilier vous construisez votre
foyer vous avez deux premiers enfants
deuxième enfant et entre 40 et 50 ans
vous allez acheter une maison un peu
plus grand dans laquelle vous allez vous
projeter un peu plus donc vous allez pas
la meubler de la même manière vous avez
pas prendre le liquide à vous apprendre
des choses qui sont un peu plus chers et
donc vous avez tout un tas de raisons
pour être un super consommateurs entre
45 et 55 ans et de vous à moi d'ailleurs
même si vous n'avez pas envie en général
vous avez soit des vieux adolescents
soient des jeunes adultes à la maison
qui consomment pour vous donc c'est très
important d'avoir en tête le super
consommateurs c'est 45 55 ans et après
il ya un âge clé et c'est là où on est
c'est là on se trouve c'est pour ça
qu'en fait le monde change sans qu'elle
ait bien compris pourquoi 55 ans un âge
intéressant lorsque vous allez me dire
où vous pourriez me dira d'ailleurs
cette courbe de la consommation des
ménages finalement ce n'est que le
reflet de leurs revenus eh bien non
parce qu'entre 55 et 65 ans alors en
france peut-être un petit peu moins vrai
mais c'est vrai partout ailleurs eh bien
vous êtes toujours sur des sommets de
vie et pourtant la consommation commence
à baisser parce que simplement vous
arrivé à maturité surtout se produit une
chose qu'il faut jamais oublier c'est
que l'âge de la cessation d'activité se
rapproche votre comportement va
privilégier plutôt les bornes que la
consommation et après derrière 65 ans
ont consommé le moins en moins pour
obtenir 70 % de
votre consommation moyenne autour de 80
ans c'est important d'avoir ça en tête
pourquoi parce que finalement nous
partageons une chose avec les habitants
des pays riches de cette planète c'est
cette photographie je vous montrerai la
même aux états unis en italie en espagne
en allemagne en france ou au japon c'est
la même chose simplement l'expression en
fait du cycle de la vie classique donc
c'est quelque chose en fait qui est
commun à tous les pays dans lesquels
finalement la consommation donc et
motivés plus par le désir ou l'envi que
la survie est bien sur cette course
n'est pas valable dans les pays qu'on
dit en développement alors concrètement
si cette courbe est valable qu'est-ce
que comment vous pouvez faire d'après
vous pour faire une première pierre de
la prospective en termes de richesse
créée en termes de croissance il vaut
mieux avoir qui dans sa société si vous
voulez avoir ou si vous voulez espérait
beaucoup de croissance plutôt
par là et si vous avez de plus en plus
par ici d'après vous ce après quoi comme
problème mais
ça pose en fait simplement un problème
de potentiel votre adn démographique est
grosso modo c'est ni bien ni mal c'est
comme ça ça s'impose à vous oh c'est une
forme de déterminisme votre adn
démographique vous oriente finalement
vers un potentiel de consommation plus
faible et c'est là on voulait vous
montrer une deuxième image deuxième
image c'est celle ci c'est en fait une
carte du monde tout simplement qui vise
à faire l'état des lieux de notre propre
vieillissement c'est ça la révolution
alors vous parle beaucoup de révolutions
numériques on à dire un mot tout à
l'heure mais la vraie révolution cette
révolution silencieuse que personne
n'aborde et qui pourtant transforme en
grenouille linde équilibre les modifie
définitivement c'est bien celui du
lyrisme on vous a mis là aussi quelques
chiffres c'est important d'illustrer
encore une fois on n'est pas dans le
commentaire on est dans l'analyse on
essaye de se projeter loin et là vous
avez poids vous avez finalement les pays
coloré en jaune vivent un petit
vieillissement commence à vieillir c'est
à dire qu'en gros les plus de 65 ans par
rapport aux gens qui ont entre 20 et 65
ans en âge de travailler commence à
devenir de plus en plus importants
proportionne en bleu c'est plus fort et
en rouge c'est beaucoup plus forte et là
vous finalement vous comprenez
finalement le panorama des taux de
croissance mondiaux depuis une dizaine
d'années voyez que le japon est leader
là dessus on en dira peut être un mot
tout à l'heure sur japon surtout que sur
le japon c'est un laboratoire c'est un
laboratoire vivant puisque ils ont
commencé bien avant 2004
a indiqué qu'ils sont dans un état de
dégradation avancée pourquoi
parce que hein alors je vais je vais
commencer par quelques petites anecdotes
que j'aime bien parce que ça fixe les
idées vous savez qu'aujourd'hui on vend
plus de couches pour un continent sur
japon que de couches pour bébé pourquoi
est tout simplement ça arrange vous avez
vous avez aujourd'hui une population de
vieux au japon est de même de très vieux
alors qu'est ce que ça a donné pas ça a
donné tout simplement depuis 25
ans depuis les années 90 un japon qui
n'avait plus de croissance en un
japon qui
donc à essayer de compenser et comment
est ce que vous compensez quand vous
n'avez plus de croissance et donc plus
de croissance de revenus puisque pierre
viens de vous expliquer que le 60 66 70
% du pib donc de la croissance mondiale
et de la croissance des pays étaient
dues à la consommation des ménages et
donc il faut bien essayer d'entretenir
cette consommation des ménages comment
vous faites pour entretenir cette
consommation des ménages il ya le seul
moyen que vous avez quand vous arrivez à
la retraite et donc a priori vous ne
pouvez plus vous reconstituer des
revenus eh bien c'est la dette et c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui où les petits
boulots ou les petits boulots les deux
d'ailleurs là alors vous avez
aujourd'hui une 1 les forces
commerciales des sociétés au japon c'est
des gens qui ont 65 70 ans
parce que c'est tout ce qu'ils trouvent
mais se
sont endettés ils se sont endettés ils
se sont endettés massivement que ce soit
l'état japonais où que ce soit les
ménages japonais est alors contrairement
à ce qu'on dit vous avez un depuis
quelques années on vous dit tout
le temps que les japonais détiennent
l'epargne
java le détail dans la dette japonaise
c'est faux ça ne l'est plus la vérité
vous avez en quelques années les
japonais qui ont perdu toute leur
épargne financière vous avez aujourd'hui
40 % des japonais qui n'ont aucune
épargne financière quand vous avez 65
ans c'est un peu compliqué de la refaire
de la reconstituer à cet égard est donc
vous endetter ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui dans absolument tous
les pays
la croissance est basée uniquement sur
la bête alors tu veux un peu vite j' y
ajoute les saillies retrait retourné
juste après mais voulait bien quand même
leur montrer leur illustré en fait cette
révolution silencieuse puis il ya un
domaine dans lequel on sait faire des
projections hormis les flux migratoires
et ça c'est un vrai sujet qu'on pourra
aborder tout à l'heure c'est celui en
fait de l'évolution de sa population
vous pourriez en fait des naissances
qu'on constate depuis un certain nombre
de décennies donc le rouge ici est
amusant au japon parce que je ne sais
pas si vous vous souvenez mais début des
années 90 quel pays dans le monde avait
réinventé le capital il quel pays dans
le monde affiché était la chine de
l'époque d'ailleurs affiché 5 4 5 6 % de
croissance par an depuis 25 ans le
japon alors de vous à moi méfiez-vous
lorsque quelque chose fait la une des
magazines en général et ça c'est plus
les investisseurs qui parle il faut le
vendre eh bien il fallait le vendre
effectivement les japonais effectivement
avait vécu de dessiner ou deux décennies
et demie de formidable croissance pour
une raison fondamentale je vous ai
montré tout à l'heure le fait que les
super consommateurs 45 50 50 les
japonais les japonais ont bénéficié
d'une chose extraordinaire qui est
simplement entre 1977 et 1995 le
doublement des gens qui sont qui ont ce
statut de super consommateurs et donc
concrètement ça apporter leur croissance
sauf que quand ça s'arrête et bien ya
plus de richesse crée effectivement
depuis mai des années 90 au japon il ya
plus de croissance y a plus d'inflation
y a plus tout ce qui a déjà disparu chez
nous mais eux avec vingt ans d'avancé
alors c'est toujours intéressant
d'envoyer que l'europe à commence à
vieillir et bon encore une fois métive
méfiez-vous des économistes ils sont
très bons pour vous réécrire le passé
vous raconter l'histoire c'est mieux si
on servait à me projeter alors du coup
on s'est dit on va aller faire un tour
un peu plus loin dans un peu plus loin
gérer d'un an dans les années à venir et
voyez quoi donc là vous avez la même
chose en 2025 qu'est ce qu'on constate
alors les leaders dans ce domaine
souvent reste leader donc les japonais
là où vous en doutez vont rester rouge
pendant longtemps un petit anecdote
aujourd'hui la population avec japonais
ses 126 millions 126 et en 2050 vous
serez à moins de 90 minutes dont qu'ils
auront perdu un tiers de leur population
donc pour tous ceux qui vous disent que
l'avenir c'est japon on pourra reparler
qu'est ce qu'on voit en fait 2025 on
voit que l'europe qu'on a atteint
finalement un deuxième stade de
vieillissement qui est important et les
pays anglo saxons également avec un
petit peu de retard 2035 voilà voilà
pourquoi en fait toutes les personnes
qui vous disent l'europe c'est le japon
en leur réponds non l'europe n'est pas
le japon aujourd'hui l'europe c'est
japon d'il ya 20 ans rhône au changement
ce que nous sommes en train de vivre les
japonais l'ont vécue avec vingt ans
d'avancé
la différence avec eux c'est qu'on peut
s'inspirer du japon on considérer que
c'est un laboratoire vivant pour
constater ce qu'ils ont fait aux qui
nous ont mis en place ou non pas mis en
place comme solution et pourrait vite il
essayait d'éviter justement de suivre le
même chemin qu'eux et qui les amène
aujourd'hui dans une situation
financière qui probablement les amènera
vers une crise du type argentine a cuit
je suis devant la monnaie et à terme la
ruine donc ça 2035 oui l'europe à terme
va voir où va afficher le même profil
démographique que le japon et donc il
est évident selon ce prisme alors 2045
ça c'est pour se faire plaisir c'est un
mécanisme en fait qui déborde sur la
plupart des pays sauf l'afrique et
l'inde aujourd'hui et en en vie on y
reviendra un petit peu plus tard donc la
conséquence forte de cette révolution
actuelle qui n'en est qu'à ses débuts
chez nous elle est très simple la taille
du gâteau à se partager qui jusque-là au
cours des 30 à carnin quarante dernières
années dans nos territoires ont augmenté
naturellement simplement nous étions
dans un monde en expansion naturelle
regard de ce que nous étions regard de
notre adn démographique ce changement ce
changement voilà de ce changement de
profil nous amène vers une taille du
gâteau à se partager
qui va avoir tendance à se stabiliser à
stagne donc ça change tout tout ce qui
vous dit est ce que nous allons nous en
sortir grâce fort autour des taux de
croissance ceni être optimiste ni
pessimiste c'est simplement comprendre
ce que nous sommes aujourd'hui notre
potentiel au regard de ce que nous
sommes temps plutôt vers une expansion
légère ou une stagnation chez nous voilà
estimons nous heureux de cela chez les
japonais c'est plutôt le déclin et dans
d'autres pays ça va être plutôt un léger
déclin les allemands les italiens
d'ailleurs sur ce sur ce plan semble pas
mieux dotés que nous donc le premier
constat qu'on fait c'est que il faut se
sortir de la tête le diagnostic il est
celui ci ceux qui vous disent que le
retour de la croissance réglera nos
problèmes mais a priori font une erreur
de diagnostic et donc il est évident que
les traitements qu'on veut mettre en
place sur cette base là ne peuvent pas
être couronnée de succès alors la
première réaction ce qu'on a constaté
c'est ce qu'évoque et olivier c'est
finalement le premier pays qu'il a vécu
a décidé de ne rien faire c'est le japon
et donc quand tu fais rien et lorsqu'on
a un adn démographique comme celui ci ça
génère quoi lorsqu'on a un modèle de
société qui a été créée dans les années
60-70 sur la base en fait d'une
population qui est s qualité et qu'en
fait cette population change et que
nouvel modèle ne change pas il se
produit quoi 7 à 10 % de déficit public
par le japon ces sept à dix points de
pipe une richesse créée par an de
déficits publics qui font gonfler quoi
une dette absolument colossal de 150% de
butt donc vous êtes aujourd'hui sur sur
des niveaux de dettes sur lequel
impossible de revenir en arrière on
le voit d'ailleurs dans la réaction des
dirigeants japonais qui ont fini par
avouer il ya quelques mois que ils ne
savaient plus quoi faire ce qui commence
à être inquiétant 1 quand vous avez le
principal monsieur
qu roda le patron de la banque du japon
et quand vous avez monsieur l'abbé
premier ministre japonais qui vous dit
là on est face à un mur et on ne sait
plus quoi faire pourquoi tout simplement
parce qu'ils se piège même c'est à dire
que quand vous avez un pays qui est une
économie qui est drogué à la dette parce
que c'est une véritable drogue vous ne
pouvez pas sevré le pays de dette comme
ça si vous sevrer le pays vous tomber en
récession immédiatement vous avez déjà
un déficit budgétaire comme le dit
pierre de 7 à 10% vous savez que le le
japon avec pourtant ce qui l'a mis en
dette depuis 2007 2008 la fin 2007
c'est-à-dire la crise la crise mondiale
le japon a un pib qui est passé de 5400
5500 milliards de dollars à aujourd'hui
katy 1950 milliards de dollars donc il a
reculé d'une dizaine de pourcents et
pourtant la dette a été colossal la
dette a ajouté a été colossal et ça vous
l'avez et vous le retrouver dans
absolument tous les pays vous pouvez
faire le même calcul en france en france
ça vous donnera 3 euros 50 de dettes
pour un euro de pipe en espagne qui est
le modèle qu'on nous ressasse en
permanence en nous disant regardez ce
qui s'est passé en espagne
la reprise est là en espagne en espagne
pendant cette même période c'est à dire
2008 2016 vous avez eu 12 12 euros 10 de
dettes pour un euro de pipe alors je
passe il ya les chefs d'entreprise ici
en face il ya des chefs d'entreprise
demandez leur si à chaque fois qu'ils
mettent 12 euros de dettes ils ont un
euro de chiffre d'affaires je suis pas
sûr qu'ils tiennent très longtemps à ce
rythme là là on est et on est dans un
dans un système qui est un système je
vous dis universelle c'est la même chose
aux états unis aux états unis vous
n'avez vous avez eu une dette qui est
passé en 1985
la dette totale c'est-à-dire la dette de
l'état la dette des ménages la dette des
entreprises représentaient 85 % du
revenu médian des américains aujourd'hui
ça représente 500 80 % du revenu médian
des américains donc si vous voulez le le
fait de d'essayer de vendre en
permanence et c'est c'est un outil de
communication le la croissance on essaie
de maintenir les populations tranquille
pendant qu'on les tons c'est plus facile
de tondre un mouton quand ils ne bougent
pas et donc on essaie de vous tenir
tranquille on essaie de vous tenir
tranquille en vous disant que tout va
bien mais malheureusement la croissance
le peu de croissance qu'on obtient
depuis 2008
est une croissance qui est artificiel
qui est obtenue uniquement par de la
bête et encore il y aurait deux il y
aurait du levier à cette dette c'est à
dire que on mettrait un euro dette et on
aurait 3 euros du pib' pourrait à ce
moment-là dire bravo mais là c'est pas
le cas et c'est loin d'être le cas et à
ce moment là vous rentrez dans une
espèce de spirale qui n'a pas de fin
c'est à dire que vous êtes obligé de
continuer en permanence pour essayer de
soutenir une apparence de croissance
vous êtes obligé en permanence dans
ajouté c'est une addiction
revenons au calme au sujet de
conférences le jour d'après alors si on
vous parle du japon c'est qu'on n'est
pas fan du japon simplement on constate
lorsque en inde à peine de mort
graphique qui change est finalement qu
on a une taille le gâteau à se partager
qu'ils nomment en plus qu'est ce qui
peut se passer si on ne fait rien la
dette explose ça veut dire quoi la dette
explose parce qu'aujourd'hui vous
pourriez nous dire finalement ils vivent
pas plus mal vous êtes allé au japon ont
peut-être vous verrez que les japonais
vivent pas plus mal en tout cas c'est
pas visible sauf qu'en réalité quand
vous fait gonfler comme ça niveau des
tout un stock de dettes aussi une
manière aussi élevé bien derrière pas de
secret vous allez légué cette dette à
vos enfants et à vos petits-enfants dire
que c'est une forme de fuite en avant le
fait de ne pas poser le bon diagnostic
fait que d'une certaine manière la seule
réponse qu'on ya fait s'il ne rien faire
et donc d'acheter finalement la
croissance ou la richesse crée de la
soutenir il ya de la dette on vous
explique le jour d'un prêt au japon
quand on vous dit que finir on ne croit
pas au japon ce qui n'est pas exactement
le cas chez nous là on s'inspire de ce
modèle là pour dire il ne faut pas faire
ça nous sommes sur le même chemin nous
avons encore le temps de changer voilà
nous européens nous américains et donc
il ne faut pas le faire pour une raison
très simple vous
allez dire c'est pas grave aujourd'hui
les japonais pour financer leurs fins de
mois et leurs déficits publics sont
descendus dans la cave et imprime des
billets de banque ces billets de banque
qu'on imprime on les donne à l'état et
du coup ça leur permet de financer leurs
dépenses publiques jusque là tout va
bien la monnaie bouge pas trop tout se
passe bien - restaurateurs si vous
donnez un billet dans la hyène jeu
contre quoi 20 relation vous me la
donnez moi en contrepartie vous donne
mon plat voilà où votre plat pour vous
nourrir le midi au déjeuner il va se
passer qu'à un moment donné et ça pour
le coup c'est impossible de le le times
et un dream est de trouver le moment où
ça va se produire va se passer que le
restaurateur un jour va venir mais dis
donc votre billet il est un peu neuf
c'est ça le problème c'est que lorsqu'on
passe dans la création monétaire sans
date de fin on est dans une situation où
à un moment donné le restaurateur qui va
vous donner votre prix va vous demander
un billet mais deux et c'est bien cela
en fait la problématique du japon le
chemin du japon les mène à la ruine
parce que ça l'amènera à la destruction
de la valeur de ce que représente un
billet de banque et n'oubliez pas qu'un
billet de banque ce n'est pas autre
chose qu'un contrat de confiance entre
vous qu'il possédait et le restaurateur
qui l'acceptent et contre croyez vous
livre un bien ou un service
et c'est ça le sujet passe à passer en
gros décembre dans sa cave fermée à clé
casser la clé et imprimer des billets de
banque à tour de bras ça peut marcher ça
peut marcher dix ans mais c'est les
populations qu'ils iront à un moment
donné je n'ai plus confiance et j'en
veux plus ça aboutit à une fuite devant
la monnaie c'est ce qui s'est passé en
argentine alors sur des pays beaucoup
moins développée au début des années
2000 la monnaie en fait s'effondrer du
coup vous rentrez dans l'hyperinflation
en gros qui tire win le pays donc voilà
ce qu'on peut encourager à faire c'est
de ne pas suivre le même chemin or vous
avez sous les yeux illustration du fait
que lou grosso modo tout le monde a fait
ouf continue de faire pour certains à
peu près la mèche la même chose
c'est-à-dire mettre en place des
politiques de création monétaire
simplement parce que nous n'avons pas
encore été capable de poser le
diagnostic et de faire les changements
nécessaires pour que justement nos
déficits publics ne ment pas alors vous
avez simplement on va faire un
commentaire pour vous ayez en tête les
ordres de grandeur ça c'est le bilan des
banques centrales peu importe c'est ce
que c'est on va dire c'est ce que 1
mettre à disposition les bancs des
centrales donc sur le système monétaire
on est passé simplement en 2008 2 à peu
près 4000 milliards $ a aujourd'hui un
peu plus de quinze mille milliards $
uniquement au japon en europe et aux
états unis oui donc on a injecté c'est
ce qu'ils voulaient illustré en fait
tout à l'heure olivier on a injecté
beaucoup beaucoup de monnaie pour un
résultat voilà certes un tout petit peu
meilleure cette année mais qui retombera
pour une raison très simple
l'absence de croissance n'est pas lié à
nos erreurs elle est liée à nos
changements essentiellement d'origine
démographique alors sachez aussi que là
il en manque une il
manque la banque de chine la banque de
chine a pris sérieusement le relais déjà
[Musique]
la chine depuis quelques
années sur investi massivement
mais
quand je dis massivement c'est bien
au-delà de ce que de ce qu'on pu faire
tous les autres pays je ne sais pas si
vous vous souvenez mais on disait du
japon dans les années 80 90 1 qu'il
bétonel et fond des rivières pourquoi
ils bétonné et fond des rivières parce
qu'il y avait tellement d'argent que il
savait pas quoi en faire et donc qui
surinvestissent et si on peut appeler ça
de l'investissement parce que ça n'a pas
grand intérêt quand même de bétonner le
fond des rivières mais
et
il le faisait parce qu'ils savaient plus
quoi faire de leur argent en chine on a
on a eu autre chose on a eu un japon
mais multiplié par deux ou par trois
vous êtes arrivé à un moment à 40% 48
% du pib en lice en investissement et on
sur investissement c'est à dire que vous
avez aujourd'hui des villes entières qui
sont des villes vide ce qu'on appelle
les ghost town ou en chine non
là
tu veux un peu vite parce que c'était
une image en fait un petit peu plus tard
voilà on va là on va la remettre mais
est ce que je veux dire c'est que
aujourd'hui vous avez depuis le début de
l'année la banque de chine qui a
sérieusement corriger
ce graphique puisque il met sur la table
par mois 400 milliards de dollars pour
vous donner aujourd'hui petite idée du
du tableau vous aviez les américains qui
pour garder leur bilan faisait 40
milliards par mois 40 milliards de
dollars vous avez les japonais qui
faisait 80 milliards de dollars par mois
et puis vous avez l'europe
monsieur draghi qui nous faisait aussi
la joie de nous mettre 80 milliards de
dollars par mois 80
milliards d'euros pardon donc 90
milliards de dollars à peu près et vous
aviez enfin les chinois qui mettait 400
milliards de dollars par mois donc vous
voyez que la planche à billets tourne et
tourne jour et nuit alors peu importe
savoir si l'une prend le relais de
l'autre de toute façon cet argent
circule mais circule pas là où il
faudrait qu'ils circulent
c'est à dire qu' il n'a même pas de
croissance en plus parce que il ya eu
cette idée au départ assez curieuse
d'ailleurs qui était l'idée que quand
vous faisiez
tourner la planche à billets eh bien ça
relancer l'économie c'est une idée assez
curieuse c'est à dire c'est de se dire
que c'est
pas le chien qui remue la queue c'est la
queue qui remue le chien en fait la
monnaie c'est quand même qu'un
intermédiaire donc si vous n'avez pas de
transactions sepa en mettant plus de
mener que vous allez avoir plus de
transactions et surtout le système qui a
été mis en place c'est à dire le système
qu'on appelle nous dans notre jargon de
quantitative easing c'est à dire les
banques centrales qui sont à la
manoeuvre et qui font tourner la planche
à billets qu'est ce que ça veut dire
concrètement aujourd'hui faire tourner
la planche à billets c'est tout
simplement acheter de la dette sur les
marchés et vous acheter de la dette et
vous le mettez dans le coffre de la
banque centrale
donc c'est quand même assez curieux de
se dire qu'en achetant de la dette et en
le mettant dans les coffres de la banque
centrale on va créer de l'activité on va
réduire le chômage et on va créer de
l'inflation
curieux comme méthode pour créer de
l'inflation et faire baisser le chômage
parce que vous avez qu'un trader a
employé qui appuie sur un bouton
désespérément toute la journée pour
acheter des obligations donc vous ne
pouvez pas avoir ni d'inflation
puisqu'il faudrait que l'argent circule
or ils circulent pas il est dans le
bilan il bouge plus c'est comme si vous
preniez bédié que vous les métiers dans
un coffre ça
va pas vous créer de l'activité et ça va
pas vous créer de l'inflation non plus
mais il y avait cette idée au départ et
donc ils l'ont fait depuis 2008 nous ont
prouvé que limete les américains ont
commencé par mettre 1000 milliards par
an et ça n'a absolument rien changé là
pour être encore pour aller un petit peu
plus loin concrètement ce que cela
signifie c'est que ce type de politique
monétaire notamment abouti et d'énormes
bulles la bulle ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que la valeur en euros d
actifs c'est comme si votre bien
immobilier prenez 100 ou 150 % sans que
finalement l'activité économique autour
de votre bien n'évolue donc ya pas de
raisons intrinsèques au fait que les
prix montent mais grâce à ce que ces
politiques monétaires mais concrètement
ça génère une bulle de valorisation à
peu près partout c'est dire que les prix
ne sont plus en gros le reflet de
l'offre et de la demande la vigueur de
la demande par rapport à notre capacité
à y répondre mais simplement d'un
artefact monétaire ça c'est le premier
point mais ce qu'il faut avoir en tête
c'est que globalement les taux de
croissance qui disparaissent le
disparaissent de manière structurelle
c'est à dire que la taille du gâteau à
se partager n'augmente plus que pour
l'instant aussi nous ne faisons rien
nous orientant vers japon et ça finira
mal aujourd'hui nous avons suivi le même
chemin nous avons généré des bulles on
peut encore revenir en arrière c'est
dans une petite divergence je pense pas
comme nous tous cas européens et
américains nous avons friel franchir la
ligne rouge qui nous permettrait de ne
pas revenir en arrière priori débat le
japon c'est trop tard clairement la
question de fond c'est qu'aujourd'hui
donc on va parler des sujets qui
intéressent en fait l'auditoire on nous
dit souvent que la croissance va revenir
grâce à quoi
grâce à qui grâce
aux investissements mais grâce à quoi
c'est quoi le père noël d'aujourd'hui
alors
l'état non l'état n'ont pour certains
peut-être mais aujourd'hui la vraie
révolution dont on parle souvent c'est
la révolution numérique et ça c'est
intéressant donc on a une vraie position
en fait assez tranché sur le sujet
la révolution numérique c'est une
révolution mais ne nous trompons pas
c'est d'abord une révolution de moyens
c'est d'abord une révolution de part de
marché c'est d'abord une révolution qui
va probablement faire tomber des gens
qui dominaient leurs marchés depuis
longtemps au bénéfice d'autres comme
peut-être ceci voilà qui vont leur
prendre leur part de marché mais ce
n'est pas une révolution de débouchés ce
n'est pas une révolution qui vous amène
plus de richesse créée au niveau agrégé
simplement la répartie de manière
différente les acteurs donc qu'ils
étaient les gagnants d'hier probablement
ne seront pas et gagner en demain s'il
ne se saisissent pas de cette révolution
de moyens premier point deuxième point
la révolution numérique tel qu'on
l'entend aujourd'hui elle permet aussi
beaucoup d'automatiser et donc elle
permet de se passer de quoi d'humains
d'emplois voilà d'une certaine manière
elle permet également quoi d'avoir un
peu plus si on se passe d'emploi pour
qu'on ait entrepreneurs d'avoir une
masse salariale un peu plus faible en
avoir des marges supérieures donc de
générer plus de profits et on constate
quoi on constate que la révolution
numérique probablement n'est pas grave
en soi c'est un outil un qui est à
disposition mais aboutit naturellement à
une captation de la richesse créée par
un tout petit nombre en gros il reste
quand un très très gros mais c'est déjà
arrivé dans l'histoire et donc les pros
le mans ça va continuer c'est à dire
qu'en fait les boîtes sera chaud se
rachètent les unes des autres et on tend
vers des situations oligo l'hôpial
oligopolistique à la romieu enfin au
pire j'irai n'ont au mieux plus tôt et
monopolistique au pire et donc la
révolution numérique elle tend vers une
forme de consultation systématique des
boîtes qui se rachètent les unes les
autres et qui pèse de plus en plus et
que du coup interfère dans le débat
public pour réformer donc ça c'est un
vrai sujet le troisième sujet c'est
quelle temps aussi donc à mal répartir
la richesse créée au sein de la
population alors vous faire un tout
petit parallèle historique là dessus
parce qu'on nous dit souvent que ça
n'est jamais arrivé quand se replonge
dans l'histoire un petit peu plus
lointaine on peut trouver des
similitudes avec l'épisode actuel et si
je passe quelques minutes c'est
simplement pour vous dire comment à
l'époque on y est répandue à cette
problématique surprenez en fait la fin
du dix neuvième siècle la fin du 19e
siècle a été alimentée par quoi une
incroyable révolution technologique
majeure invention
d'électricité qui permet quoi finalement
ce qu'on a connu au cours des 20
dernières années électricité la machine
à vapeur le transport et pour la
première fois au monde on délocalise
entre guillemets le lieu de production
du lieu de consommation premier
phénomène en fait de délocalisation donc
ces inventions la aboutisse a énormément
d'innovation qui créent de la richesse
cette révolution de moyens qu'on évoque
qui font que des métiers traditionnels
disparaissent au profit d'autres métiers
qu'on va faire différemment et tout ça
génère beaucoup de croissance 20 ans 30
ans de très forte croissance où tout se
passe bien pas c'est bien ça le sujet
lorsque la taille du gâteau à se
partager augmente même si la répartition
de la valeur ajoutée est très haut dans
la répartition des revenus et très
inégalitaire c'est pas grave parce que
ça augmente suffisamment pour que même
celui qui est le moins bien traitées
touche quand même quelque chose c'est ce
qu'on appelle acheter la paix sociale et
c'est pour ça qu'on réclame de la
croissance parce que c'est concomitants
andrew globalement il n'y a pas de
troubles n'y a pas de frictions et à
l'époque qui s'est produit à peu près la
même chose aujourd'hui les taux de
croissance ont commencé à diminuer
naturellement parce que finalement tout
cette innovation technologique et à
porter ce qu'elles avaient apporté bien
vous savez comment il répondu comment
déjà ont répondu les entreprises en tant
que tel lorsque la taille du gâteau à se
partager n'augmente plus l on fait quoi
elles se sont rachetés elles se sont
rachetés les unes les autres jusqu'à
n'être que plus que quelques unes
finalement et c'est ce qu'on appelait
des trusts les grands trusts donc des
grandes entreprises qui faisaient tous
donc et qui pour continuer leur
expansion individuel n'avait d'autre
choix d'aller racheter leurs concurrents
et donc on arrive en a abouti à des
entreprises qui était très puissante
notamment d'un point de vue politique et
qui commençait à devenir des concurrents
de l'état premièrement deuxièmement le
taux de croissance disparaît ou
diminuent autant avant lorsqu'il
augmenter fortement les populations à
accepter finalement une inégalité
inégalités salariales qui était forte
elle était forte mais à partir mans où
la taille du gâteau à se partager nomme
en plus à ceux qui gagnent beaucoup
c'est au détriment de ceux qui ne
gagnent rien il se passe quoi
naturellement les troubles sociaux avec
émergents du syndicalisme notamment fin
du 19e siècle terrorisme à l'époque
d'origine anarchistes mais grosse vague
de terrorisme au 19e siècle et surtout
quoi et c'est ça qui est très
intéressant
cette impossibilité pour les plus
pauvres populations de supporter un
modèle finalement très inégalitaire qui
était soutenable avant mais ne l'est
plus aujourd'hui ça aboutit à quoi fin
du xixème siècle début du xxème et bien
non pas la guerre un jeune général tout
le monde répond la guerre mais non la
réalité c'est que la réponse alors on va
prendre les etats-unis qui sont un
modèle pour le coup assez intéressant à
regarder de près c'est une élection
c'est la politique qui a répondu parce
que ça peut être une des réponses si les
populations ne sont pas contentes a
priori dans une démocratie a normalement
les gens qui les représente tous ceux
qui vont porter les discours qui leur
convienne vont finir par être élu eh
bien c'est la réponse qui ont porté les
américains d'innocents et je parle des
états unis pourtant chantre du
libéralisme
ce qui n'était pas le cas à l'époque
élection de theodore roosevelt qui
correspondrait à peu près à jean luc
mélenchon en france pour vous dit en
fait l'eau chaude ou son seul programme
était très simple si on va trop loin et
qu'on n'est pas en capacité de repenser
des modèles inégalitaire qui ne sont
plus supportables dans la population
simplement parce qu'il ya plus de
croissance où il ya moins de croissance
et bien les gens voteront pour des gens
qui diront simplement une chose je vous
découperez en fête s'ouvre au début du
xxème pendant une dizaine d'années une
période durant laquelle le politique est
entre guillemets a tenté de reprendre la
main sur l'économique et a fini par y
arriver avec la loi antitrust nous crois
de mémoire qui doit être de 1911 puis
après derrière la guerre s'est rajouté à
cela pour d'autres raisons pour des
raisons qui sont pas complètement
éloigné mais mais qui sont pas connectés
mais il faut bien comprendre ce
mécanisme là ce mécanisme qu'on vit
actuellement ce vaste semaine de
consolidation qui est naturel une boîte
naturellement vous naturellement vous
voulez grandir et donc si elle veut
continuer à grandir mais malheureusement
que taille du gâteau à se partager
n'augmente plus et bien c'est au
détriment des autres et ça
concrètement ça génère des troubles des
troubles sociaux et si on n'est donc pas
capable de remettre en place des modèles
moins inégalitaire de recréer du lien
concrètement ces troubles la pourront
peut-être se reproduire et donc
aboutiront à des votes donc la réponse
sur le jour d'après cette situation
actuelle pourrait être des votes pas
aujourd'hui mais demain parce qu'on est
au milieu du mouvement problème
aujourd'hui à des votes qui seraient des
votes qu'on va appeler populiste de
droite du but de gauche peu importe les
vote d'aujourd'hui sont surtout des
vôtres antilles et donc ça mais c'est
pas quelque chose de conjoncturel c'est
pour moi quelque chose de structurel qui
ne fait qu'exprimer le décalage entre un
modèle qui était supportable liane
trentaine ou une quarantaine d'années
qui ne l'est plus devenu aujourd'hui et
ne le redeviendra plus pour les raisons
de départ qui fait qu'il est
malheureusement en fait la croissance la
forte croissance en tout cas a disparu
donc la révolution numérique vous aurez
compris que certes c'est une superbe un
superbe sujet pour les financiers parce
que ça va rebattre les cartes d'un point
de vue à l'intérieur des secteurs
d'activités entre les acteurs mais
n'apportent pas entre guillemets ce
surplus de richesse convoqué qu'on
évoque régulièrement alors la troisième
point qu'on peut aborder donc on a du
coup on a dit la solution en tout cas la
non solution qui est de ne rien faire
sans d'été c'est prendre un risque en
tout cas c'est league est quelque chose
d'assez désagréable pour enfants
deuxième solution révolution numérique
concrètement ça va changer beaucoup de
choses mais ça va pas changer entre
guillemets au notre environnement de
croissance le troisième point c'est le
père noël finalement c'est effectivement
et si les autres nous sauver les autres
c'est qu' aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'a
commencé à évoquer olivier tout à
l'heure ce sont les pays émergents alors
les pays émergents oui mais pas tous le
problème il est il est là c'est que le
problème démographique vous le retrouvez
dans absolument tous les pays on vous a
dit sauf l'afrique
l'afrique va
d'ici 2050 avoir
un milliard de plus en terme de
population si
tout se passe bien nous aussi tout se
passe bien c'est à dire pas de famille
pas de maladie pas de de guerre fera pas
trop
en ce moment c'est mal parti mais bon et
donc vous êtes dans une vous n'avez
qu'une seule région au monde g l'afrique
subsaharienne qui a une démographie qui
leur permet d'avoir une dépopulation
de moins de 15 ans la plus élevée au
monde vous êtes aujourd'hui en train de
passer en 2015 2016 on a passé le cap où
les la population de plus de 65 ans dans
le monde est supérieure à la population
des inférieures à cinq ans ça
veut dire que les pays vieillissent et
vieillissent très vite donc et
malheureusement pas tous c'est à dire
qu'en fait dans le monde sait pas
homogène tous à dire que vous êtes face
à des pays qui n'ont plus de croissance
mais qui concrètement voient leur
population stagner ont finalement c'est
pas trop grave ça prouve et et provoquer
des troubles sociaux une remise en
question des modèles mais face à cela
vous avez des populations qui continuent
d'exploser qui sont déjà en fait
extrêmement jeunes notamment et qui pour
autant n'ont pas grand chose à manger
donc ça forcément ça pose des problèmes
on va avoir des problèmes non seulement
les problèmes de croissance que nous on
n'arrivera pas à résoudre même si un
pierre et non pas la poisse en ligne de
nature plusieurs textures de plus
optimiste que moi mais
et vous allez avoir des problèmes de
migration des problèmes de migrations de
populations parce
que il est assez clair que cette
espèce de grand écart qu'on fait en
termes de pas de rémunération mais de
richesse globale de la population va
entraîner un effet aspirants qui risque
de nous de
nous apporter pas mal de migration du
sud vers le nord est on peut dire un mot
d'ailleurs pourquoi en fait aujourd'hui
finition n'est finalement pas d'ailleurs
au summum détention ou de cette volonté
en fait de flux migratoires parce qu'il
faut quand même pas oublier que beaucoup
en fait deux pays entre guillemets euros
originellement pauvres on va dire qu'ils
ont émergé pour certains d'entre eux
fait ont été tiré par une locomotive
c'est pour ça quelques échanges chinoise
que tu évoqué tout à l'heure et très
intéressante en gros si les autres nous
sommes c'est à dire que ben notre
croissance faible tant pis on ira
chercher la croissance là où elle se
trouve c'est à dire ailleurs mais pour
aller la chercher encore faut-il qu'elle
existe et il s'est passé quoi dans ces
pays où il ya eu de la croissance
pendant 15 ans palin est tellement la
dette pendant un certain temps mais
cette croissance elles dépendent qui
elle dépend d'un seul pays et d'une
locomotive qui s'appelle la chine la
chine c'est 40 % de consommation des
matières premières industrielles à elle
toute seule la chine c'est 15 % de
consommation de pétrole nicolas pour en
dire non probablement donc à elle toute
seule ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
cette émergence d'un pays qui n'existait
pas sur la scène internationale rappelez
vous quand même que avant 2000 ans la
chine cc n'existe pas sur la scène
internationale et en 15 ans elle va
devenir quoi l'atelier du monde 25 à 30
% la production mondiale et fabriqués là
bas en 15 ans elle va devenir quoi
premier exportateur mondial aujourd'hui
à peu près un combat mais bon alors
qu'elle elle n'existait pas alors on
doit être à 12 % des exportations
mondiales en provenance de chine alors
qu'elles devaient à 2 en 2000 donc ce
formidable mouvement il a fait quoi il a
fallu qu'il a fallu investir et pour il
a fallu produire et pour produire et
investi en consomme quoi des matières
premières et finalement les pays pauvres
un atout et un actif qui s'appelle quoi
en général pas leurs matières premières
et donc faut bien comprendre qu'il ya un
mécanisme qui fait qu'en gros il n'ya
pas d'émergence naturelles dans le monde
il y a eu quoi il ya eu un pays qui a
émergé de manière extraordinaire
fantastique alors près derrière les
leviers aujourd'hui en fait sont sont
plus dispo à disposition mais on peut
pas nier qu'il ya là beaucoup cru elle
est devenue en fait un acteur majeur sur
la scène internationale en une quinzaine
d'années et ça ça aboutit à quoi à
l'augmentation des prix des matières
premières parce que pour le devenir cet
acteur majeur elle en a consommé
beaucoup sauf que c'est terminé
et ça marche dans un sens donc en gros
il faut vraiment avoir l'image sur les
pays émergents et pays en développement
d'une locomotive et des suiveurs et
lorsque la chine tous et c'est la
probabilité fait trop la chine nous nous
vivons une crise de maturité s'il
fallait donner une image eux vont vivre
plutôt une crise d'adolescence c'est pas
exactement la même chose parce qu'ils
ont fait n'importe quoi et pour soutenir
la croissance ils ont trop investi on va
être très concret un camp dit troupe
investissez cause qu'est ce que ça veut
signifie ça veut dire qu'on investit
dans les routes on investit dans des
voies ferrées on investit dans des
aéroports si en fait dans des immeubles
je ne sais pas si l'image est là juste
après voilà dans des villes aussi dans
l'immobilier mais y'a personne dedans
donc au moment où on fait ça sacré quoi
c'est ce fameux modèle espagnol je
rappelle fallait pas et je vais le dire
peut-être mais sorti de saint cyr pour
en 2006 comprendre qu'un espagne en
espagne il y avait une bulle et en gros
ça finirait mal parce qu'en 2006 en
espagne en construisait autant qu'en
france allemagne et espagne réunis et
bien en fait la chine depuis quelques
années ce n'est plus qu'un grand
exportateur c'est un grand inspecteur
exportateurs ça reste mais c'est devenu
aussi finalement un peu le modèle
espagnol ou en investi dans tout dans
des proportions colossales en levant
beaucoup de dettes parce qu'il faut pas
oublier il faut pas voir ce pays avec
nos yeux un que les raisons pour eux de
7 sur investissements de soutien de la
croissance qui a duré jusqu'à maintenant
qui devrait s'arrêter oui on
va passer aux questions fait que
aujourd'hui le pays en fait ne peut plus
continuer à investir dans la phase
d'investissement pour investir et pour
construire il faut employer des gens si
vous employez des gens vous leur donnez
des revenus malheureusement une fois que
tous aient tous et tous ses outils de
production là tous ces aéroports toutes
ces routes sont construites s'il n'y a
pas d' usage qui en est fait mais
concrètement le projet s'arrête vous
lisant si les gens vouloir donner plus
de revenus il ne consomme plus et donc
c'est le mécanisme inverse qui se met en
place et donc en fait on en est là en
chine on a investi dans tout dans des
proportions colossales en vend beaucoup
de têtes et aujourd'hui doivent gérer ce
problème là donc imaginé pour nous en
tout cas pays occidentaux et développer
que la croissance des autres pourrait
compenser la faiblesse de la nôtre est
probablement un petit peu risqué quand
on sait qu'aujourd'hui la probabilité de
connaître une crise d'adolescence pas
forcément en 2018 mais peut-être en 2019
à 2020 donc là on est con et demain pour
le coup est très importante et avec elle
elle entraînera l'ensemble du monde en
développement alors ça c'est le côté
passif puis vous avez le côté actif
parce que vous avez aujourd'hui une
guerre économique une guerre des
monnaies vous avez bien vu que les
américains jouent sur laure dollars les
chinois jouer sur leur monnaie aussi en
la mettant sous pression est donc en
ayant une monnaie faible ce qui a amené
à un moment les américains à leur
demande et de la faire remonter parce
qu'il trouvait que la concurrence était
déloyal il ya une guerre monétaire
aujourd'hui qui qui n'est pas qui est
qui est déclarée qui est officiellement
déclarée vous avez vu récemment que les
chinois et les russes ont conclu des
accords pour se dé dollarisée c'est à
dire passer
d accord pour acheter le pétrole par
exemple pour les chinois pour acheter le
pétrole russes en les payant en yuan
convertible en dollars on part donc en
or excusez moi et donc pour éviter
d'utiliser le dollar alors nous ont bien
aidés les américains puisque je vous
rappelle que parce que certaines banques
utilisaient le dollar on a eu des
amendes record la bnp s'en souvient
encore 9 milliards froid et donc vous
avez beaucoup
de gens qui aujourd'hui beau et surtout
dans les pays émergents beaucoup de gens
qui essaient de sortir de cette
hégémonie du dollar et là attention
danger danger pourquoi parce que on peut
imaginer savait
que les chinois achètent à tour de bras
de l'or en ce moment c'est la banque
centrale c'est pas juste pour faire des
bijoux et des boucles d'oreilles donc
c'est la banque centrale qui achètent de
l'or on peut se poser la question on
peut se demander s'ils sont pas en train
avec les russes probablement d'élaborer
une stratégie pour remplacer
le dollar remplacer le dollar ça
pourrait se faire comment petit scénario
qui pour l'instant n'est qu'une fiction
mais dans deux ou trois ans ils peuvent
sortir leurs réserves de change il en
avait quatre plus de 4000 milliards ils
sont descendu à moins de 3000 milliards
dont qui peuvent sortir à peu près 700
milliards par an donc il en reste moins
de 3000 donc vous voyez que c'est pas si
éloigné que ça et ils peuvent sortir une
monnaie alors une
crypto monnaie ou pas une crypto monnaie
d'ailleurs on peut importe mais ils
peuvent sortir une monnaie qui est
entièrement basée et convertibles sur
l'or ou sur un panier or argent ou sur
de l'or de l'argent et puis des terres
rares par exemple ils en ont je vous
rappelle 90% de la production dans le
monde donc ils sont assez à l'aise là
dessus et s'ils font ça ils
deviennent le nouveau dollar ce qu'il
est évident que si vous
me vend des quelque chose et que vous me
proposez et que je vous propose d'être
payé soit en
euros ou en dollars soit en yuan
convertible en or j'ai
peur que vous ne choisissiez la
troisième solution ce qui veut dire que
les américains risquent de ne pas être
content le namaz vont jouer avec leur
hégémonie sur le dollar le temps passant
on fait ce qu'il faut retenir en fait ce
qu'on veut de vous dire aujourd'hui
c'est qu'en crawl et transformation
convient aujourd'hui problement sont
beaucoup lit à nos propres
transformation et vendre outillés en
fait à des tensions qui vont augmenter
structurellement elles vont pas saper au
paiement au contraire tant qu'on n'aura
pas modifié entre guillemets les modèles
dans lesquels nous vivons en fait elles
continueront de s'exacerber des tensions
entre pays olivier viande invoqué une
potentielle et de tensions entre pays
d'un point de vue économique détention
entreprises d'un point de vue
migratoires quand certains vivront avec
une forme de déclin quand d'autres
auront à gérer une population qui
explose il est évident que cela
occasionnera des troubles des troubles
et des tensions entre entreprises c'est
ce qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure on voit
bien que la seule solution pour
continuer à s'étendre c'est de racheter
l'autre et donc vont se multiplier des
stratégies non coopératif qui poseront
problème à terme et des troubles aussi
au sein même des populations en tant que
tel puisque nos modèles relativement
égalitaire supporter grâce à la
croissance le seront de moins en moins
et donc ce faisceau de trouble n'est pas
conjoncturel et les il correspond
essentiellement à nos propres
transformation alors on va tout de suite
vous passez la parole parce que derrière
là on a posé un constat et je pense que
peut-être qu'on peut ouvrir le débat sur
les solutions qu on m en qu'on peut
mettre en place pour essayer d'éviter
finalement que ces troubles se
matérialise par une rupture parce que
c'est ça le sujet imaginez que les
troubles disparaît c'est peu probable
est-ce qu'ils déboucheront sur une
rupture si on les adresse mal c'est
quasi évident alors merci pour votre
attention et l'objectif était aussi de
mettre en place un débat donc la parole
est à vous aidant élie keyrouz mercier
olivier quelques petites consignes
pratiques pour les questions je vous
d'attendre d'avoir le micro de lever la
main pour l'avoir d'attendre d'avoir le
micro d'être très concis dans vos
questions pour laisser le maximum de
temps à nos orateurs alors je crois que
pour commencer on a une première
question internet peut-être donc le
messieurs dames bonjour une question de
l'internet est actuellement mais plus de
mille vous regardez une question pour
pierre sabatier pour reprendre les
termes de pierre savatier quel point de
rupture pour acheter la paix sociale en
france et une question plus pour olivier
delamarche le japon est essentiellement
endetté envers lui-même emprunts publics
est il obligé de rembourser pour
l'interrogation le japon la population
les japonais ne peuvent-ils pas tout
simplement répudier leur dette et
une question personnelle votre avis sur
le salaire universel n'y
répond pas alors
la première question excusez moi mais
j'ai mal entendu je vais te l'a répété
oui pour reprendre les termes de pierre
sabbatique quel point de rupture pour
acheter la paix sociale en france quel
jeu comprend pas très bien la question
le point de rupture alors le covoiturage
permet d'évoquer en fait les quelques
pistes qui sont valables pour notre pays
en tant que tel puisque l'on ne peut
jouer que sur ceux voilà ce qu'ont à
disposition et ça permet d'y répondre le
point de rupture ça pourrait être
synonyme du fait que nous ne comprenions
pas que le monde dans lequel on vit est
tendue les tensions vont continuer que
ça cesse de s'exacerber et que nous nous
dotons pas des armes que les autres
utilisent et ça c'est absolument crucial
pour ça que le premier point qui est
important pour répondre à cela pour
éviter cette rupture et de ne pas la
dépasser c'est comprendre que la
régulation elle est nécessaire elle est
nécessaire pas pour se doter d'un
avantage comparatif mais au mois pour
faire disparaître en gros les dumpings
qui existent par ailleurs et pendant
trop longtemps pendant une quinzaine
d'années finalement l'europe parce
qu'elle est idéologues elle est souvent
dogmatique a finalement était la seule à
joindre les actes à la parole alors que
les américains sont les premiers à
défendre leurs intérêts manière plus ou
moins directe et les chinois sont les
premiers défenseurs atterré manière plus
ou moins directe donc il faut comprendre
que la régulation alors on rentrera pas
dans les bacs qui doit la faire la
france l'europe limite on s'en fiche
mais il faut la faire en gros il faut
faire en fait la régulation pour
simplement jouer avec les mêmes armes
que les autres grand amateur de rugby
nous assure si vous faites jouer au
football un acteur lui disant vous avez
droit joué que les règles du rugby il
est sûr que celui ci gagnera et bien
voilà c'est ce qu'il faut éviter éviter
que dans notre jeu de football on est
des gens qui jouent avec les règles du
rugby parce qu'on y perdra
systématiquement je laisserai le
deuxième point c'est donc pour olivier
le troisième point qui naissaient série
cruciale pour éviter en fait la rupture
nous semble-t-il saidal et j'irai
faire le contraire de tout ce qu'on a
fait pendant 30 ou 40 ans sur un sujet
bien spécifique qui est celui de la
politique territoriale dont on a
beaucoup parlé et qu'on n'a jamais
véritablement devrait véritablement fait
parce qu'en fait toute cette croissance
qu'on a accumulées pendant des années
elle aboutit à quoi elle aboutit à la
concentration de cette croissance de
cette richesse créée ou dans les
métropoles systématiquement et donc on a
créé des bassins d'emploi de plus en
plus important mais uniquement dans les
métropoles il a débouché sur quoi sur le
fait que nos enfants qui ont du talent
et qui sont en réalité ou qui sont
période bénite et ils ont fait quoi
lorsqu'il finalement ont eu leur diplôme
ils sont partis ils sont partis dans ces
métropoles pour trouver un job et
construire la famille et vous trouvez
avec une situation sur le même
territoire parce qu'on n'a pas prolongé
fléchi en amant à ce sujet là la
cohésion territoriale avec des
métropoles avec une strate sociale bien
identifiés et de la ruralité avec une
strate sociale viennent identifier il
n'y a plus aucune lieux et plus aucun
lieu finalement où ces classes sociales
là se parlent et lorsque les classes
sociales ne se parlent pas elles
finissent par se battre parce qu'elle ne
se comprennent plus est donc un des
premiers gérer des premières manières
pour éviter la rupture éviter la rupture
brutale c'est se comprendre mais le
préalable à se comprendre c'est se
connaître et le se connaître ça passe
par une politique de cohésion
territoriale après on peut rentrer dans
le détail comment on fait la politique
fiscale problement éviter en fait un
salaire minimum partout le même sur le
territoire parce qu'en août quand on
fait ça ben tu la ruralité tout
simplement parce qu'elle ne peut plus
offrir aux entreprises son seul atout à
savoir sa compétitivité prix en gros ça
coûte moins cher à fabriquer là-bas
voilà donc tout ça en fait ça peut être
un préalable à recréer du lien
simplement pour que sur les territoires
les classes sociales se côtoient ce qui
n'est plus le cas
alors
je vais rebondir sur le sur l'aspect
territorial des choses c'est
exactement la même chose au niveau des
pays c'est à dire recréer une cohésion
et recréer surtout une diversification
aujourd'hui vous avez des pays qui à
cause de la mondialisation
depuis plusieurs années sont spécialisés
on ne vous a dit tout à l'heure la chine
celle usine du monde le japon s'était
uniquement les exportations de matériel
électronique le le le l'allemagne c'est
uniquement les exportations de dans
l'industrie mécanique et dans
l'automobile le l'italie c'est la
mécanique de haute précision ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que le jour où il
ya un problème dans le mono
modèle que vous avez et le pit cool et
devient systémique qui fit finalement
alors que si on avait aujourd'hui au
lieu d'essayer à tout prix d'aller vers
le service l'industrie
tertiaire et
ne l'oubliez tout ce qui est industriel
agricole etc vous avez aujourd'hui des
pays qui ne sont absolument plus
autonome et donc quand vous n'êtes plus
autonome et que vous avez un pépin
qu'est ce que vous faites vous avez
tendance à regarder dans l'assiette du
voisin et c'est là que les problèmes
commencent donc je pense que une des
premières choses mais malheureusement il
faut que ce soit fait au niveau mondial
et ça c'est pas gagné parce
qu'à part manger des petits fours
pendant lé g20 on n'a jamais vu quand
même quelque chose de concret ressortir
de ce genre de réunion et donc
il est il est clair que il faudrait
qu'au niveau mondial on réfléchisse à
recréer une certaine autonomie de des
pays des principaux pays alors
évidemment vous avez des pays qui ne
seront jamais autonome malheureusement
mais tout de même de recréer une
certaine diversification dans les
activités des pays gros
ça veut dire quoi politiques fiscales
revues pour ramener en fait des emplois
sur le territoire politique industrielle
nécessaire parce que lorsqu'on sait que
la probabilité d'une rupture sur eux
augmentent ça veut pas dire qu'elle
surviendra mais qu'elle augmente et bien
on se prépare et une manières se
préparer ces jeux permettent d'être
autonome je rappelle quand même quelque
chose qui est rarement évoquée on dit
beaucoup modèle allemand les allemands
été brillant sur plein de points ils ont
été très courageux dans dynasty qu'ils
ont posés ils lui ont apporté des
solutions alors on pourrait discuter
bonne mauvaise mais en tout cas ils ont
plutôt subi un bon chemin au cours des
15 années en dépit en fait d'un
potentiel assez mauvais ils ont fui
aussi le chemin ils ont eu de la chance
donc ils sont sont hyper spécialisés
dans les exportations mais ça veut dire
quoi quand ça va bien ailleurs les
exportations en gros ça veut dire les
importations des autres donc ça sous
tend le fait que ça se passe bien
ailleurs il se passe quoi quand ça se
passe mal ailleurs et que vous avez
transformé autres modèles et qu'il
dépend beaucoup des autres eh bien vous
perdez en autonomie il se passe que
quand ça va mal chez les autres bah vous
tombez plus fort et c'est déjà ce qui
s'est produit en allemagne n'oublions
pas que la crise de 2008 2009 qui a pas
duré longtemps finalement puisqu'on l'a
tout de suite enrayée grâce à des
politiques monétaires de dons qui ont
été brutales et est alimentée par de la
dette l'allemagne a est tombé deux fois
plus fort que la france 6 % de la
richesse créée la chute contre 3% en
france voyez donc on peut pas avoir le
beurre et l'argent du beurre et il est
vrai que l'hyper spécialisation c'est
risqué lorsque voit là la probabilité
d'une rupture a tendance à augmenter non
non je réponds pas sur la répudiation de
la tête par les japonais sur la la
répudiation et japonaise pourquoi pas
mais la question de fond tout à l'heure
on a bien évoqué le fait qu'un billet de
banque c'est un contrat de confiance si
on a fait n'importe quoi pendant 40 ans
et deux jours là on a fait n'importe
quoi ben nakad oublier fait la question
la valeur d'une monnaie c'est bien en
fait ça crédibilité sur la scène
internationale
les japonais peuvent le faire mais
concrètement comme pas quelles valeurs
allaient vous donner à la monnaie qui va
suivre derrière hockey est une vraie
question de fond c'est celle de la
crédibilité ça serait trop simple ça
serait trop facile d'éliminer finalement
des décennies de mauvaise gestion par an
n'a qu'a oublié merci
pour ces premières questions internet et
on avait des questions dans la salle je
crois bonsoir
vincent le beller de l'école de guerre
une petite question que vous avez parlé
essentiellement au départ de la
démographie problème démographique
excusez moi le est ce que en complément
d'une politique de cohésion territoriale
à la politique une meilleure politique
familiale pourrait pas être aussi
l'ambition c'est j'ai très faim et vous
et c'est pas pour vous faire plaisir
dans le monde qu'on viennent d'écrire il
ya trois budget sur lesquels on arbitre
jamais jamais quoi selon nous la
politique familiale soutiennent la
natalité pas pour viser trois ou quatre
pour viser 2 parce qu'il faut avoir en
tête dans le monde moderne naturellement
s'il ne fait rien pour soutenir la
natalité pour qu'elles tendent vers 2
n'y va pas naturellement si vous faites
rien aussi vous mauvaise politique
familiale ça tend vers un 4 1 3 1 2 et
ça c'est à terme extrêmement difficile à
gérer en termes de politiques publiques
donc il faut un soutien une politique
familiale efficace alors c'est peut-être
là on était les meilleurs dans le
paysage international malheureusement le
quinquennat précédent à attaquer gérer
ce moteur principal qui finalement nous
sommes dans 20 ans voilà donc politique
familiale il faut pas y toucher il faut
qu'elle soit toujours renforcé problème
il ne faut pas faire d'égalitarisme dans
ce domaine là on y reviendra s'il
voulait plus tard deuxième budget c'est
de l'éducation en gros parce que la
politique familiale et vous assure
d'avoir suffisamment mains de tête donc
à échéance pour vous permettre d'avoir
un des niveaux de croissance ils sont
convenables deuxième chose l'éducation
parce que il c'est bien beau d'avoir des
gens il faut aussi qu'ils soient
capables et donc l'éducation et la
formation c'est un budget qui est
absolument nécessaire et sur lequel on
n'arbitre pas pour des problèmes
conjoncturels et troisième point c'est
pas pour vous faire plaisir mais c'est
la défense parce que dans le monde qu'on
vienne décrit elle est évidente les
tensions ne se règle pas naturellement
et concrètement il vaut mieux être
préparés que pas préparés à gérer ces
tensions la souhaitant qu'il n'y ait pas
de rupture mais s'il y en a il vaut
mieux de préparer donc il ya trois
piliers qui sont ceux ci qui font que
tout le reste on peut se permettre d
arbitrage mais sur ceux ci selon nous en
tout cas on doit pas les faire merci
pierre on avait une autre question le
micro oui bonsoir dire de loin ce je
voulais savoir est ce que pour vous la
croissance ce n'est pas finalement la
disponibilité de l'énergie enfin
l'énergie disponible par personne et je
oui une bonne transition et la meilleure
la ccvg suspecte d'avoir je suis payé en
sous-main jeu visant à blanchir une
stratégie avec mathieu donc voila mais
dans tous les cas d'un point de vue
économique je vous demande ça à vous
parce que est ce que donc on peut dire
que finalement la croissance c'est
d'énergie disponibles par par citoyen et
donc aussi pour monsieur vian et ce
qu'il a entendu je sais que oui parler
d'astrid et ou en étant skis à des
verrous technologiques total sur astrid
nicolas aura droit à sa série de
questions tout à leur joie en cause
c'est que ma réponse est selon moi non
et que nicolas ira plus loin dans le
détail en fait de ceux de sa vision
bonsoir
captain à connaître car sur votre gauche
pardon et coloniale je voulais avoir
votre avis sur la théorie de la
décroissance le tien nhien tuba pour moi
c'est un fait alors soit je suis trop
auvergnats pour être où je passais
intellectuelle mais ils sont les
théories les noms mais la théorie de la
croissance ou la théorie de la
croissance c'est ça c'est à l'encontre
de tout ce que je viens enfin de tout ce
qu'on vient d'évoquer savoir qu' on
n'est pas pro croissance ou pro
décroissance en réalité ce que nous
sommes nous offre un potentiel donc si
ce potentiel il est positif vous aurez
la croissance les japonais aujourd'hui
auront probablement fait en tout cas
dans les décennies à venir un potentiel
de création de richesses qui leur fait
créer de moins en moins de richesses et
donc ils seront des croissants mais là
encore c'est la croissance sépare c'est
une conséquence c'est une conséquence en
fait de ce que vous êtes
de votre de vos envies vos besoins est
ce que vous avez dans la poche pour les
transformer en actes savoir la
consommation c'est comme ça en fait
c'est donc c'est la théorie de la
décroissance j'y souscris pas comme je
souscris pas à la théorie de la
croissance c'est une conséquence tout
comme l'inflation quand on évoque
souvent dans le débat économique est une
conséquence l'inflation la décrète pas
l'accession c'est une chose toute simple
c'est si la demande augmente il faut du
temps pour que l'outil de production
voilà je puisse la servir et ça ça
s'appelle l'inflation mais s'il n'y a
pas de demande qui augmente il y aura
pas d'inflation est donc enfin moi je
peux prendre les paris et revenir dans
une dizaine d'années et vous verrez
comme au japon on aura bien eu du mal à
générer de l'inflation tout comme de la
croissance merci beaucoup olivier et
pierre je crois qu'on arrive au terme la
de du temps qui vous était un parti
parce que nicolas s'impatiente au
premier rang merci beaucoup pour ces ces
premières analyses vous êtes quand même
très fort vous nous avez expliqué vous
nous avez expliqué qu'on avait un
problème démographique et qu'il fallait
absolument éviter la guerre venir à
l'école de guerre pour me dire faites
l'amour pas la guerre c'est vraiment
brillant
petit
problème
technique en a perdu la télécommande
c'est
bon bon merci
pour cet exposé très intéressant donc on
avait parlé le thème d'aujourd'hui
c'était le jour d'après vers un nouveau
paradigme économique et énergétique
on a parlé de l'économie et
moi ce que je vous propose c'est de
parler un peu d'énergie et de pétrole le
pétrole ce n'est pas un sujet très sexy
on va essayer de le rendre le plus sexy
possible dans les limites dans les
limites du possible mon intervention
aujourd'hui elle va se passer en deux
temps déjà essayé de comprendre est ce
que notre économie dépend de l'énergie
pour rebondir sur la question qui a été
posée et plus précisément du pétrole et
ensuite de se projeter d'imaginer le
jour d'après et plus précisément le jour
d'après pétrole est ce que si jamais un
jour n'en avais moi est ce que ce serait
grave quel
impact sur notre économie quel impact
sur nos vies et
finir par des pistes de solution si
jamais ce jour arrivait alors
je vous propose de commencer par une
petite prise de hauteur sur l'économie
mondiale depuis à peu près de milan donc
on se place à l'époque de jésus-christ
j'aime bien cette citation d'albert
bartlett sur la fonction exponentielle
la plus grande faiblesse humaine vient
de son incapacité à
comprendre la fonction exponentielle
donc
aujourd'hui ensemble on va essayer de se
renforcer on va essayer de comprendre la
fonction exponentielle qu'est ce que
c'est la fonction exponentielle c'est
une fonction dont la valeur double à
intervalles de temps réguliers par
exemple le pib entre 72 et 94 22 ans à
double
entre 94 et 2014 20 ans sa double donc
on est sur un schéma de fonction
exponentielle à sa patte toujours été le
cas bien évidemment une
autre citation que vous pouvez lire
celui qui croit qu'une croissance
exponentielle peut continuer
indéfiniment dans un monde fini est soit
un fou selon un économiste mais
il peut aussi être prix nobel vous avez
c'est pas incompatibles vous avez un
prix nobel qui s'appelle robert fogle
prix nobel d'économie en 1981 13 il
écrit un papier en 2007 il se projette
en 2040 et en 2040 y voit le pib mondial
à 250
alors c'est derrière la 250 milliards de
dollars donc on est bien sûr notre
fonction exponentielle et on continue à
doubler en 20 ans 20 ans et puis on
continue à augmenter pour la petite
blague sur les 250 milliards la moitié
c'est la chine 125 milliards de dollars
et l'europe et l'europe nous sommes à 15
15 milliard de dollars 1 10e ben on va
quand même un truc qui est intriguant
c'est qu'est ce qui s'est passé là en
1870 alors bien on a un peu parlé ce qui
s'est passé en 1870 c'est que vous avez
une révolution industrielle qui a
commencé en angleterre notamment avec
l'utilisation du charbon et quand 70 en
fait c'est la première mondialisation
permise par le développement 1 du
champion de fer et deux des bateaux à
vapeur qui fonctionne donc au charbon et
on commence à délocaliser la production
et c'est là que l'économie commence à
décoller alors le pétrole est découvert
en 1859 mais on peut pas tout mettre sur
le dos du pétrole lors ce qui est quand
même intéressant à souligner c'est que
le royaume uni figurez vous c'est aussi
le pays donc c'est le pays la première
révolution industrielle mais c'est aussi
le pays qui a aboli l'esclavagé
il sauf que ça se passe exactement au
même moment qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
alors ils se sont toutes deux très
bonnes âmes au royaume uni mais ils sont
surtout rendu compte qu'avec le charbon
il pouvait produire la même chose dix à
cent fois moins cher donc ils sont tout
simplement au lieu de prendre des
métiers à tisser qui fonctionnent avec
des gens plutôt avec des avec des
machines et c'est comme ça et finalement
qu'on a remplacé ses
travail d'esclave par des esclaves
énergétique et aujourd'hui vous êtes
dans un monde qui fonctionne
effectivement avec des esclaves
énergétique je crois que c'est en gros
par personne en moyenne 200 esclaves
mondiale
bon
alors une fois qu'on a dit ça on va
essayer de faire un petit zoom quand
même sur cette période intrigante juste
un petit sondage dans la salle vous levé
juste ne doivent pas vous demander à
chacun qu'est ce qu'ils pensent que ça
va continuer de monter on
est avec des pessimistes l'âge est
impressionnant ainsi quand même au fond
quelques mains qui se lèvent et qui
pensent qu'on va peut-être partir dans
ce sens là ouais
bon
et alors plutôt vers le bas je
te vers le bas bon pourquoi
pas alors
l'énergie très rapidement l'énergie
c'est une notion qui est un peu
compliqué parce que quand on essaie de
suivre dans les médias ce qui se passe
pourtant du temps il vous parle de ça
c'est ce qui est en verre là alors c'est
plus 2% et 3% ça s'appelle les nouvelles
énergies renouvelables ce sont le
solaire et puis l'éolien nouvelle parce
qu'en fait au moyen âge on était déjà
100 % renouvelable figurez-vous avec de
l'hydraulique et du bois bon on est
passé de 100 % renouvelable à 80%
fossiles et on reviendra un jour 100%
renouvelable probablement la question
c'est à quel niveau alors
on a fait un petit zoom vous voyez ici
derrière c'est le pib mondial donc on
voit le charbon l'énergie de la
révolution industrielle
juste que finalement la la la seconde
guerre mondiale et le pétrole voilà
qu'on a découvert un peu plus tôt qu'on
utilise au départ dans nos lampes c'est
du pétrole lampant on se rend bien vite
compte que ce n'est pas forcément bon
usage et l'électricité vient sortir le
pétrole et puis après on a fort doté au
début du xxème qui a entre l'as la
voiture pour tout le monde la voiture
pour tout le monde le pétrole a une
importance dans le première partie du
20ème siècle notamment au niveau des
guerres haut niveau la première guerre
mondiale puisque l'armée
américaine quand elle débarque et
motorisé c'est la première armée
motorisés et on aura à nouveau
importante dans la seconde guerre
mondiale puisque à partir du moment où
en 1943 les
américains et les français iront
bombarder les infrastructures de pétrole
dont l'allemagne dispose est soit en
roumanie soit chez eux pour faire du
pétrole à partir de l'inite vous avez un
tournant dans cette guerre mondiale qui
fait que qui fait que l'aviation
notamment allemandes et clouées au sol
tournant qu on a d'ailleurs vu plus
récemment plus près de chez nous en
syrie puisque vous avez une opération
qui était commencée
par vladimir poutine qui fait qu'à
partir du moment où on a commencé à
bombarder
les installations de l'état islamique au
niveau du pétrole qui était une source
de revenus importante pour eux c'est là
où finalement vous avez sorte de pics de
l'état islamique et que et que depuis
privé de ses ressources petit à petit
ils ont perdu du territoire lors ce qui
est intéressant d'ailleurs c'est que
l'opération des alliés il ya quelques
années ce appelée tide always tout et
que en 1943 pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale ça s'appelait taille du wave
pour
la petite histoire alors
donc ça c'est ce qu'on parle 97 pour
tant de temps et là on à l'énergie
fossile vous veillez les trente
glorieuses voilà c'est ça beaucoup de
pétrole pas cher un petit rocher en 1970
premier choc pétrolier et pour ceux qui
pensent que le charbon c'est l'énergie
du passé et bien non puisque le charbon
on en a jamais consommé autant et si les
trente glorieuses se sont faits sur
beaucoup de pétrole très bon marché et
bien la croissance de ces dernières
années s'est fait sur beaucoup de
charbon c'est une croissance au charbon
puisqu'en 2001 vous avez la chine qui
rejoint l'om sait et c'est pour ça que e
on est alors pour la petite histoire ce
qui regarde le régisseur de co2 vous
savez on a des objectifs en europe de
faire baisser nos émissions de co2 et on
est très bon depuis 1990 puisque nos
émissions ont baissé de 10%
qu'est ce qu'on a fait on a fermé les
usines en france on les a mis en chine
en europe de l'est ça a très bien marché
et c'est pas que les émissions de co2
sur ses émissions de polluants associés
etc manque de pot si on réintègre
les importations et qu'on retire les
exportations c'est plus moins de 10%
mais plus 10% alors
le pétrole est ce que ça a un impact sur
notre économie quand
on regarde finalement les 40 dernières
années on se rend compte que quatre
quatre des cinq grandes crises ont été
liées au pétrole là vous avez d'abord le
premier choc pétrolier on en a parlé il
est là le premier choc pétrolier qu'est
ce qui s'est passé en 1970 les
américains se rendent compte qu'ils
arrivent à un maximum de production de
pétrole qui ne vont plus pouvoir
augmenter leur production et donc ils
vont voir l'iran et l'arabie saoudite
pour leur proposer en sous-main
d'augmenter progressivement le prix du
pétrole pourquoi pour pouvoir ensuite à
les développer des nouveaux champs en
alaska en europe en mer du nord et donc
c'est pas exactement l'histoire qu'on
vous a vendue le premier choc pétrolier
c'est surtout les américains se rendant
compte qu'ils arrivaient un maximum de
production maximum de production qui n'a
jamais été atteint à nouveau depuis
qu'ils
sont allés faire augmenter les prix
deuxième choc pétrolier la révolution
islamique donc l'a priori c'est pas les
américains
vous avez ensuite quelque chose qui est
intéressant ici en 1986 vous voyez les
prix du pétrole qui baissent très
fortement qu'est ce que c'est c'est le
contre choc pétrolier avec les
américains qui s'arrange avec l'arabie
saoudite pour pouvoir produire un
maximum de pétrole et pouvoir faire
baisser le prix pour que les revenus en
devises étrangères de la russie baisse
qui aboutiront cinq ans plus tard à la
fin ou la pose de la guerre froide et
l'effondrement de
l'urss 91
bien en irak 2001
c'est pas le pétrole non cette fois ci
c'est là c'est la bulle internet
et puis vous avez finalement le subprime
ce prime pétrole ou
pas alors pourquoi est-ce que le
subprime c'est probablement lié au
pétrole qu'est ce qui se passe en 2001
en 2001 vous avez la chine qui qui
rejoint l'om c'est comme le disait
pierre la chine qui est un ogre en terme
de matériaux et en termes de et un terme
d'énergie et donc vous avez la demande
de pétrole qui augmente très fortement
l'offre qui augmentent moins vite
mécaniquement les prix augmentent quand
les prix du pétrole augmentent ça a
tendance à faire de l'inflation c'est un
produit sous jacent donc beaucoup de
choses augmente et quand vous avez de
l'inflation qu'est ce que font les
banques centrales elles
augmentent leurs taux d'intérêt bon
vous avez peut-être déjà acheté un
appartement je ne sais pas généralement
en france nous machete avec des taux
fixes mais vous avez les paieries on
peut plutôt acheté qu'un taux variable
donc quand le taux d'intérêt de la
banque centrale au monde est votre taux
il augmente aussi et c'est ce qui s'est
passé en partie aux etats unis c'est à
dire que vous avez un certain nombre de
ménages subprime donc qu'ils n'avaient
pas les moyens de se payer leurs biens
qui ont été pris à la gorge par cette
augmentation des taux est liée à
l'augmentation des taux d'intérêt donc
un lien à nouveau sur le pétrole petit
commentaire sur ce petit pic que vous
avez connus en juillet 2008 qui était
lié à l'époque à pékin les jeux
olympiques de pékin la chine qui avait
acheté beaucoup de pétrole
et puis une certaine dose de spéculation
vous avez ri aussi donc il semblerait
que le pétrole et à l'impact et un rôle
dans notre économie pourtant quand on
nous parle d'économie on nous explique
souvent l'économie c'est très facile
c'est du
travail du
capital et
ça vous fait du pib la croissance alors
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui du
travail y en a beaucoup 6 millions de
chômeurs du
capital y en a beaucoup on l'a vu tout à
l'heure avec les quinze mille milliards
de dollars de dettes des banques
centrales et du pib il n'y a pas
beaucoup donc quelque part on a
peut-être oublié quelque chose dans
l'équation entre
entre le travail et capital en fait ce
qu'on a oublié c'est que dans le travail
aussi l'énergie et quand un être humain
compte pour un belle
énergie comme je voulais dit comme pour
et pourquoi est ce qu'on l'a oublié
parce qu'en fait si on prend le secteur
énergétique dans le pib sa part c'est
10% donc on se dit c'est 10 % du pib
donc son importance c'est 10% g
j'écoutais récemment jean marc jancovici
satin connaissent peut-être qui dit
qu'il faisait un parallèle assez marrant
donc j'ai vu jouer leur propre mais il
vous dit en gros vous votre cervelle ces
2 % de votre poids donc c'est pas
important essayer
et si sans cervelle voir ce que ça donne
alors vous me direz que je sais que
certains y arrivent très bien et
que malheureusement souvent ils ont des
responsabilités
mais
ceci étant dit c'est beaucoup plus dur
alors quelque
chose d'intéressant voilà ça c'est la
croissance du pib mondial en trillions
de dollars donc en bleu croissance du
pib mondial en triant dollars qu'est ce
que c'est anvers bien envers c'est une
modélisation de ce pib juste en fonction
de l'extraction du pétrole d'accord donc
on dit combien de barils de pétrole ont
extrait terre et vous voyez que
visiblement
il y aurait un lien et qui marche à
l'air très très fort
quand le pétrole est contraint l'offre
de pétrole et comptera comme des années
70 - ici puisqu'on perd 2 contre choc
pétrolier et plus ensuite 95 2008 et il
se trouve que vous avez d'autres
personnes comme l'économiste gaël giraud
qui a fait des travaux comparables en
fait il fallait pas à garder la part du
pétrole dans le pib il fallait voir la
part de la croissance du pétrole dans la
croissance du pib et quand vous regardez
ça vous voyez qu'en fait le pétrole
c'est 60% il a fait un travail sur des
séries longue d'une quarantaine d'années
pour 50 pays l'énergie
explique 60% de la croissance le capital
15% donc on a du pétrole on
à la croissance on a moins de pétrole la
moindre croissance donc
l'accession d'après c est ce qu il en
reste beaucoup du pétrole alors
est ce qu'il reste beaucoup pour faire
tourner notre économie et notre et nous
voiture aussi d'ailleurs alors là j'ai
essayé de vous expliquer quelque chose
en deux minutes que qui m'a appris à peu
près de 10 ans à comprendre donc si vous
comprenez pas c'est pas grave mais je
vais quand même faire mon possible pour
y arriver il
ya 40 ans on me disait il reste quarante
ans de pétrole aujourd'hui
il reste toujours 40 ans de pétrole et
donc
cette histoire de pic pétrolier on se
revoit dans le 40 ans et puis il en
restera toujours 40 ans et puis on se
fait une bouffe on sera content bon non
en fait c'est pas si simple que ça ce
que je vous propose c'est de faire un
parallèle avec votre compte en banque
mais
tous un compte en banque la plupart des
personnes qui n'ont pas de prix du
bitcoin donc un compte en banque
ça va être votre réserve et
ça va être la réserve de pétrole et puis
après on va regarder l'extraction
de pétrole et ça c'est votre plafond
combien vous pouvez prendre d'argent par
semaine d'accord on va raisonner comme
ça on va on va commencer par regarder
votre compte en banque et les réserves
en fait quand on vous parle des réserves
de pétrole on vous parle de cette chose
là ce serait là c'est en gros ce qu'on
appelle les réserves financières et
politiques c'est à dire que par
convention quand on a commencé à compter
les réserves pour les entreprises pour
protéger les investisseurs ont déclaré
une valeur qui étaient les réserves
prouvées d'accord donc c'était très
pessimiste dans 90% des cas vous alliez
en trouver plus donc on avait tendance à
sous évaluer les réserves et au fur et à
mesure qu'on en trouvait plus dans le
même champ on les rajouter au fil de
l'eau et puis politique pourquoi parce
qu'un jour dans les années au milieu des
années 80 vous avez en fait la façon de
produire du pétrole au moyen-orient
c'est une politique de quotas donc les
gens produisent en fonction de leur
réserve bon si vous voulez produire plus
qu'est-ce que vous faire augmenter vos
réserves et donc du jour au lendemain
vous avez des pays du moyen-orient qui
s'ils ont tous mis et vous avez 300
milliards de barils en anglais andy out
of ciner donc du jour au lendemain vous
augmentez 300 milliards ses réserves
politique alors
ça c'est bien mais ce qui compte c'est
plutôt celle là et ça c'est les réserves
techniques les regards technique c'est
une information qui n'est pas disponible
parce que c'est une formation très
confidentiel qui sont détenues par
souvent soit les compagnies pétrolières
soient les états est en fait dans ce cas
là df des réserves techniques dans le
coeur du sujet après ce sera moins dur
met donc les réserves techniques tout à
l'heure je vous disais on était très
précis mis cela c'est plus les réserves
prouvées c'est éprouver plus probable
donc il ya 50% de chance qu'ils en aient
plus est à 50% de chances qu'ils
allaient mois donc a priori quand on les
met toutes ensemble on se trompe pas
trop et on les met à chaque fois où de
la découverte du pétrole est pas au fil
de l'eau et ça vous donne ça donc ça
c'est ce qu'on voulait c'est ce que vous
voyez dans les médias et
ça c'est ce qu'il ya dans la vraie vie
donc
si on reprend nos calculs en
gros effectivement
si on prend ses réserves financières et
techniques eh bien vous aviez donc
trente
ans de pétrole alors on ne voit pas ici
mes 30 ans de pétrole ya 40 ans et puis
maintenant vous en avez 60 ans a
augmenté quand on prend l'autre histoire
parce
qu'en gros ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que depuis 1981 on consomme plus de
pétrole qu'on en découvre donc forcément
ça baisse et là vous voyez qu'en fait et
bien il ya 40 ans il nous en restait 60
et qu'aujourd'hui c'est 30 donc ça
baisse je vous demande pendant 40 ans
qui restera on peut reparler à ce moment
là mais en vo votre compte en banque ubs
sachez le mes le compte en banque c'est
pas très grave pour l'économie parce que
l'économie c'est un flux le pib c'est
pas un stock donc on va regarder plutôt
votre votre capacité à prendre de
l'argent toutes les semaines est ce que
vous êtes capable de vous aviez un
plafond à 500 euros est ce que demain
pourrait prendre six cents euros 700
euros vous avez deux géologues
pétroliers qui sont être posé la
question en 1998 ils ont dû attendre
leur retraite pour pouvoir parler
librement et ils ont dit à l'époque
d'ici dix ans nous allons avoir une
contrainte sur la disponibilité de
pétrole conventionnel
en gros ça veut dire pétrole pas trop
cher qu'on peut récupérer avec les
techniques conventionnelles donc pas le
pétrole de roche-mère aux états unis et
ils ont averti voulait avertir la
population de deux de ces choses là
qu'est
ce qu'il en est aujourd'hui
il en a qui effectivement le prix du
pétrole augmente pourquoi parce que le
coût d'extraction du pétrole augmente
c'est presque rassurant on est allé le
chercher au départ là où ça coûtait pas
cher et puis aujourd'hui ça coûte de
plus en plus cher d'aller le chercher
quand on va arabie saoudite vous
extrayez aujourd'hui un baril de pétrole
sur des champs existants ça va vous
coûter 5 à 10 dollars si vous ouvrez un
nouveau champ ce sera plutôt 25 dollars
si vous aller en mer c'est un petit peu
plus compliqué en mer là c'est plutôt 40
à 50 dollars si vous allez aux états
unis avec le pétrole de roche-mère vous
faites d'abord un trou vertical puis un
trou horizontal puis vous mettez un
liquide que vous envoyez de pression
c'est un peu plus cher 50 à 70 dollars
si vous allez un arc tic conditions sont
pas idéales en arctique s'est encore un
peu plus cher et donc le prix du pétrole
augmente bon ça vous fait une belle
jambe et la question c'est jusqu'à
combien est-ce
que c'est jusqu'à 80 et jusqu'à combien
on va pouvoir se le payer surtout 80 $
100 $ 200 dollars car souvent on a on a
une impression un peu que le pétrole
c'est quelque chose qui coûte cher un
baril de pétrole vous savez combien de
litres de dans 159
litres dans un baril de pétrole donc si
je prends un baril de pétrole à 80
dollars le litre me revient à 50
centimes donc c'est moins cher que de
l'eau minérale typiquement vous en buvez
un peu plus puisque en france et 3
litres par personne par jour alors que
l'eau minérale c'est plutôt entre 1
litre et 1 litre et demi donc le pétrole
c'est pas cher mais c'est pas ça le
sujet le sujet c'est qu'en fait on a
constaté que à partir d'un certain prix
eh bien vous commenciez à détruire de la
demande de pétrole qu'est ce qui se
passe mais il se passe que les gens
qu'au moins le moins le moyen de se
payer le pétrole bat il le sent
consomment moins ils laissent leur
voiture au garage et prennent leur vélo
ils font autre chose et donc c'est ce
qu'on a constaté la vous avez le cas au
niveau du second choc pétrolier
n'étaient déjà plus de 100 $ en
dollars constants et puis où on l'a vu
récemment aussi 2011 2012
et donc le pic pétrolier c'est ça en
fait le pic pétrolier c'est vous avez
vos coûts d'extraction du pétrole qui
augmentent et
puis après vous avez une capacité à
payer des gens qui elle se situe autour
de 120 dollars est-ce que ça monte
est-ce que ça baisse la tendance est
plutôt à la baisse pourquoi ben vous
avez quand même des pays un certain
nombre de pays qui
en ont profité avec le pétrole peu cher
pour baisser leurs subventions
typiquement l'arabie saoudite a augmenté
le prix de son pétrole de 50% on est
passé de 13 centimes d'euro à 20
centimes d'euros 13
centimes à 20 centimes d'euro et en même
temps vous avez des pays consommateurs
qui eux le
pouvoir d'achat alors appât pour les 1%
il y aura pas de problème toute façon et
roulantes et cela donc pas besoin de
pétrole mais pour les autres le pouvoir
d'achat plutôt tendance à diminuer et
donc en fait le pic pétrolier c'est ça
c'est à dire qu'on va aller chercher
tout le pétrole disponible sous nos
pieds qu'on pourra se payer voilà bon
est-ce que c'est 100 dollars est-ce que
c'est 120 dollars est-ce que c'est 150
dollars ça va pas changer grand chose ça
va décaler on pourra gagner un peu de
temps on pourra imprimer un peu de
pétrole peut-être avec nos banques
centrales mais un moment donné ça va
peut être coincé alors
dans les faits qu est ce que ça donne
parce que ça c'est un dessin ça c'est
juste un dessin pour comprendre alors
la production de pétrole depuis 1975
elle est la seconde choc pétrolier hop
totof voilà 2005 qu'est ce qui se passe
en 2005 contrainte
c'est pour ça que les prix augmentent
donc finalement nos géologues pétroliers
jean laherrère et coline gamble bas ils
s'étaient trompés parce qu'il avait dix
10 ans en fait ça s'est passé en sept
ans c'était un peu plus tôt mais bon on
leur en veux pas trop ce qu'il n'avait
pas prévu c'est que en 2005 jordan du
bush je
viens de le faire dans cette affaire
georges d'abel du bush
dans une loi sur l'énergie exemple en
fait les
fluides utilisés pour la fracturation
hydraulique d'un certain nombre de lois
environnementales donc
des lois pour protéger protéger l'eau
pour protéger leurs pour protéger l'eau
potable clean air act clean water act et
safe drinking water act qu'est-ce qui se
passe et bien grâce à ça les états unis
commencent d'abord par faire de la
fracturation hydraulique pour développer
des ressources en gaz de roche mère et à
partir de 2011 comme les prix du pétrole
sont plus de 100 dollars est bien là il
commence à plutôt aller chercher du
pétrole de roche mère et donc du pétrole
anticon non conventionnelles qu'on
retrouve ici et cette croissance dans
l'approvisionnement de pétrole c'est les
états unis mais c'est aussi le canada
qui vous savez les canadiens qui sont
très fort avec une énergie très
renouvables produisent beaucoup de
pétrole bitumineux un peu mois
renouvelable un peu plus sale et
aujourd'hui on en est là donc
2015 2016 2017 on sera sur une
production de pétrole mondiale stable
qu'est ce qui se passe ensuite en 2018
il se passe que comme depuis 2014 on a
divisé par deux quasiment les
investissements pour aller chercher du
pétrole et pour faire des projets alors
ça prend un peu de temps à développer un
projet est bien ça risque un peu de
coincer bon
alors
imaginons qu'on a une contrainte sur le
pétrole qu'est ce qui se passe ensuite
il
se passe ensuite que en fait quand vous
avez un pic pétrole vous allez
vraisemblablement avoir un pic tout est
en anglais c'est beaucoup plus chic ça
fait peak oil vous fait un pic hall peak
oil picole pour les anglophones alors
il se trouve que en 72 heures il y avait
des chercheurs du hem haïti qui ont
publié un rapport du club de rome où
finalement ils ont fait un modèle
systémique alors ce qui est étrange
c'est que ce modèle systémique en fait
nos économies nos économistes ne
raisonne jamais en systèmes seco a
résonné en système ça veut dire d'acs en
gros la terre est ronde voilà la terre
est ronde les arbres ne montent pas
jusqu'au ciel ça c'est les hypothèses du
modèle donc abandonné on a une
contrainte qui se passe sur les
ressources et la contrainte se traduit
dans le pib dans la population mondiale
et dans un certain nombre de choses
qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit ces gens là ils
ont dit en gros au rythme auquel nous
progressons en 1972 entre 2010 et 2030
ça risque de coincer c'est vraiment ça
leur message il faut pas aller chercher
beaucoup plus loin il faut se méfier
alors
est ce qu'il existe aujourd'hui déjà des
cas de pic pétrolier autour de nouveau
est ce que quelqu'un connait un cas de
pic pétrolier norvège
effectivement quand
bretagne aussi puni
lui là bas vous me donnez tout mais pays
mais d'abord j'avais envie de parler un
peu de cuba mais bon tant pis on va
quand même par les impôts de cuba cuba
effondrement de de
l'urss entre 1800 1989-1993
consommation
de pétrole moins 50% alors c'est un pays
consommateur parce que nous on est
consommateur donc j'essaie de regarder
des consommateurs moins 50 % en quatre
ans voilà déjà les cubains non
mais allez voir ce que ça donne alors
après vous avez la grèce la grèce plus
près de chez nous moi je pense qu on est
plutôt sur le modèle grec alors le
modèle grec c'est quoi 2007-2013
-40% sur la consommation de pétrole
six ans donc ça va assez vite et
effectivement moi qui pensait que
l'union européenne n'avait
pas vraiment de politique en termes
d'énergie en fait si elle est très
peut-être très consciente du pic
pétrolier c'est pour ça qu'elle fait des
politiques d'austérité très forte
puisque c'est ça qui fait beaucoup
baisser la consommation d'énergie alors
on a parlé d'un certain nombre de pays
effectivement la norvège le royaume-uni
ici vous retrouvez à 1 74 75 c'est bien
les pic pétrolier les chocs pétroliers
qui ont permis d'aller développer le
royaume uni et la norvège et qui a filé
quand même un sacré coup de main à
madame thatcher à l'époque je pense que
ça l'a bien aidé et puis vous avez
d'autres pays comme
le yémen on n'en parle pas trop dans les
médias un
peu plus récemment l'egypte
la syrie vous avez aussi cité le
venezuela donc ça c'est des pays
producteurs de pétrole effectivement qui
ont connu un pic pétrolier la chine
aussi d'ailleurs pour information a
connu son pic pétrolier la chine c'est
le cinquième producteur mondial et même
si je dis pas de bêtises 5 ou 6 et
demain vous aurez peut-être aussi
l'arabie saoudite qui s'est alors
moi je presse je voudrais qu'on regarde
un peu le cas la syrie rapidement
qu'est ce qui s'est passé en syrie en
syrie pic de production en 96 à
partir de ce moment là vous avez une
baisse ici des exportations en rose
guînes
baisse mais je pourrais dire une chute
parce qu'en même temps qu'est ce qu'il
ya vous avez une croissance
démographique en syrie qui fait que la
consommation de pétrole augmente aussi
et
donc les
exportations baissent donc les
revenus de l'état qui dépend des jusqu'à
60% du pétrole en 2001 en 2007 c'est 20
% à 60 % à 20 % bon
bah qu'est ce qu'on fait dans ce cas là
on augmente les impôts pas très
populaire qu'est ce qu'ont fait d'autres
on peut augmenter des taxes on peut
baisser les subventions pas
très populaire vous rajoutez à ça en
2010 extrêmement
mauvaises récoltes vous avez une partie
importante de la population rurale qui
vient en ville pour trouver du travail
et vous avez en gros des conditions
entre
guillemets parfaite pour qu'au moindre
étincelle vous ayez donc ce printemps
arabe qui s'est passé
et qui sait dans un second temps
dégrader alors pour information le pib
de la syrie aujourd'hui
on est au même niveau qu'en 1990 il a
baissé de 60% et a priori pour revenir
aux niveaux de 2010 ça va leur prendre
20 ans alors
je préfère la grèce à la syrie un jeu
très franc avec vous bon la syrie alors
dans un monde où il ya moins de pétrole
comment on fait et avec qui il faut être
amis c'est important ça par exemple
quand vous voyez la grosse flèche ici
qui va du canada aux états unis vous
vous dites bon les américains ils vont
éviter de se fâcher avec le canada parce
qu'ils en ont besoin quand vous voyez la
grosse flèche ici qui va du moyen orient
iran arabie saoudite vers la chine vous
dites la chine va peut-être pas déclaré
la guerre tout de suite à l'arabie
saoudite parce qu'ils en ont besoin en
toute logique quand vous voyez la grosse
flèche ici de la russie vers l'europe
vous dites bon ce serait quand même con
que l'europe se fâche avec la russie ça
reviendrait à peu près à scier la
branche sur laquelle nous sommes assises
alors
d'ailleurs figurez vous que les russes
qui eux peut-être un peu plus plus
habiles sont devenus la flèche n'est pas
là mais c'est aujourd'hui le premier
fournisseur comme le dit olivier de la
chine en pétrole
devant l'arabie saoudite donc si nous
n'en voulons pas ils trouveront
quelqu'un d'autre à qui il va
effectivement il se trouve que la russie
c'est quand même un tiers du pétrole
importé en europe comme on ne produit
pas
c'est à peu près un tiers de notre
consommation 40% du gaz et
donc c'est quand même un allié dont on a
dont on a besoin en france arabie
saoudite en gros qu'est ce que ça veut
dire notre plus gros fournisseur de
l'arabie saoudite ça veut dire que quand
le baril était à 100 dollars eh bien on
leur donnait chaque année 10 milliards
d'euros par an alors la bonne nouvelle
c'est que ces 10 milliards ils ont
promis nous les rendre en partie avec
les contrats d'armes qu'ils ont proposé
à manuel valls je crois qu'on l'attend
toujours mais ils valent ces temples au
pouvoir peuvent être plus difficiles 10
milliards d'euros c'est l'ordre de
grandeur choix c'est huit milliards
d'euros je parle sous contrôle de pire
conessa du budget de l'arabie saoudite
depuis 40 ans pour exporter l'idéologie
salafiste en dehors de ses frontières
alors c'est pas que notre argent bien
sûr mais on y contribuer peut-être un
peu est ce que ça nous coûte cher ce
pétrole on l'a dit 50 milliards d'euros
par an il se trouve que quand
on regarde il ya quand même une
sensibilité importante de notre déficit
commercial aux
prix du pétrole notamment
depuis
2000 qu'est ce qui s'est passé en 2000
mais là vous avez la chine dans l' omc
et puis vous avez aussi les nouveaux
états membres de kem un certain nombre
d' usine qui partent de france d'europe
de l'ouest vers l'europe de l'est c'est
d'ailleurs assez flagrant si on regarde
l'automobile l'histoire dans
l'automobile en gros entre 2010 et 2012
vous fermer 12 usines d'assemblage en
europe de l'ouest et vous en ouvre et 11
en
europe de l'est qui fait que bas avant
on vendait des voitures aux autres et
maintenant on en achète alors françois
hollande a été très bon parce
qu'il a réduit le déficit commercial bon
il était là au bon moment quand le prix
du pétrole est divisé par 2 forcément ça
aide un peu
quand on regarde pas le pétrole mais le
reste c'est un peu moins beau sur la
photo voilà ça c'est l'industrie
manufacturière donc on les prix vont
réaugmenter la note va être salée à
quoi sert le pétrole c'est la question
qu'on doit se poser à quoi sert le
pétrole en fait les le pétrole c'est
devenu l'énergie reine du transport en
étant l'énergie reine du transport c'est
l'énergie de la mondialisation donc
plus de pétrole plus de mondialisation
moins
de pétrole
et bien là on va être plutôt sur de la
relocalisation le transport c'est 95% du
pétrole pourquoi parce que tout
simplement est ce que certains d'entre
vous sont déjà tombés en panne de
voiture est-ce
que vous avez poussé votre voiture
peut-être
sur cinq ou dix mètres bon c'est
fatigant si vous prenez cette bouteille
d'eau qui fait un peu plus qui fait 50
centilitres et vous la remplacez de
pétrole eh bien elle vous poussera à
votre voiture sur 10 km ça c'est le
pétrole beaucoup d'énergie dans une
petite bouteille d'eau donc c'est pour
ça qu'on le prend pour le pour le
transport et donc demain on a moins de
pétrole mais la bonne nouvelle c'est que
elon musk et là alors
cette phrase elle est vrai pour beaucoup
de choses à chaque problème complexe
il existe une solution simple et fausses
on
a la solution alors si monsieur même ken
parce que j'aime bien citer ceux qui
disent des choses intelligentes bon la
seule de la voiture électrique je vais
pas vous en parler pendant deux heures
en gros au niveau mondial c'est une
voiture à charbon puisque 40% de
l'électricité provient du charbon vous
n'avez pas d'impact sur l'énergie
consommée parce que ça consomme beaucoup
d'énergie de produits à la batterie vous
déplacer de votre contraintes du pétrole
vers les métaux le lithium le cobalt
donc on est très fort pour déplacer des
problèmes un peu moins pour les résoudre
l'impact
sur la pollution en ville il existe mais
en fait si vous voulez réduire la
pollution il suffit juste de limiter les
voitures polluantes ça marche beaucoup
mieux et c'est beaucoup plus efficace et
ça peut se faire d'un claquement de
doigts et puis le problème de la voiture
électrique c'est quand vous allez partir
en vacances demain et vous allez faire
500 km ça va vous prendre pas cinq
minutes pour faire le plein ça me prend
deux heures un peu plus long deux heures
c'est si vous arrivez à la borne et que
vous êtes tout seul il a une par station
s'il ya quelqu'un devant vous ça fait 4
heures et quand
le week-end de l'ascension vous faites
10 heures pour faire 500 km vous partez
le mercredi matin ou jeudi matin vous
arrivé vendredi soir et puis pour partie
de samedi matin pour revenir assez
rapidement vous comprenez qu'il ya un
problème est qu'en fait quand on va
devoir prioriser les usages du pétrole
la longue distance c'est du pétrole
l'avion c'est du pétrole le bateau c'est
du pétrole le camion c'est du pétrole et
la voiture aussi
par contre pour ceux qui sont venus en
voiture tout seul aujourd'hui ça ce sera
plus possible on pourra plus on pourra
plus gaspiller le pétrole dans une
voiture en ville alors que vous auriez
pu lui prendre un vélo un bus en métro
vos pieds ça marche aussi ou alors venir
en covoiturage avec d'autres personnes
qui venaient aussi à cette conférence
alors vous savez je vous ai dit les
énergies renouvelables 85%
des choses on ne parle 95% du temps ça
marche aussi pour la voiture électrique
figurez vous voilà les ventes de
voitures électriques alors ça c'est la
norvège bon c'est une voiture sur deux
pourquoi parce que la taxe est 100% donc
la voiture vos vins vous payez 40 ça
marche un mariage parce qu'ils sont un
peu plus riches chez nous je suis pas
sûr que ça marche beaucoup et nous on
est là voilà dans le petit carré alors
comme je suis sympa je voulais a grandi
voilà donc la voiture électrique c'est à
peu près 2% des ventes donc
dans la salle si on est allé 502% vous
faites le calcul ça fait pas vraiment
une une ou deux personnes en voiture
électrique voilà pour la voiture
électrique bon mais vous n'avez pas aimé
la voiture électrique j'ai autre chose
de mieux la voiture autonome électrique
alors
[Musique]
là j'ai pris une photo en 2040 et vous
avez effectivement des voitures qui sont
toutes autonome électrique et là on se
dit mais il ya un truc qu'on a loupé bah
oui il ya un truc qu'on a loupé c'est
que le problème de la voiture c'est pas
qu'elle soit électrique
ou pas électrique et le problème de la
voiture c'est qu'on est tout seul dedans
donc ça prend beaucoup trop de place on
et 1,3 en moyenne et quand on va au
travail 90% du temps on est tout seul
donc c'est ça c'est vraiment ça le
problème et donc quand on regarde les
solutions du transport qui vont être
valable en fait pour l'économie en
général
je vais essayer de faire des parallèles
en fait on est dans un monde où on a une
infrastructure en place qui est très mal
utilisé on a des voitures qui roulent 5%
du temps 95% du temps elles sont à
l'arrêt c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
parfois vous avez du mal à vous garer
parce qu'elles sont toutes gares et
quand elles roulent 5% du temps on et
1,3 personne dedans 30 % 30
% soit 5 % ça fait une infrastructure
utilisé à 1 5% c'est
peu on va pas faire 100% mais 1,5 c'est
pas beaucoup aujourd'hui
vous avez des systèmes ou en entreprise
ont fait du de l'autopartage autopartage
on n'utilise pas la voiture 5% mais 40%
x 8 et puis vous avez aussi des systèmes
de covoiturage pour aller au travail
avec votre collègue et donc vous êtes
plus tout seul mais vous êtes deux dans
la voiture 40% et là ça vous a coûté
zéro zéro zéro centime 40% autopartage
40% covoiturage ça fait 16 % 0 00
centimes fois disent d'accord donc il va
falloir faire beaucoup mieux avec ce
qu'on a et en fait ça ça marche avec
tous des
voitures plus petites pour moi consommer
ça s'appelle de la sobriété plus
de personnes par voiture ça s'appelle de
l'efficacité et moins de voitures ça
s'appelle aussi de l'efficacité
efficacité
énergétique alors quelques exemples de
sobriété la sobriété c'est le de rouler
en voiture vous prenez une voiture plus
petite ou un scooter ou un vélo
l'efficacité
alors il ya d'autres choses qu'on peut
faire un par exemple ça veut dire de la
typiquement quand on fait du covoiturage
si vous vendez votre voiture et vous
faites du de l'autopartage par vous
l'utilisez deux fois moins donc on
utilise moins souvent c'est la sobriété
où vous pouvez rouler moins vite c'est
aussi la sobriété et
efficacité efficacité
me remplit mieux utiliser alors on peut
regarder d'autres secteurs n'y a pas que
le transport ya pas que le pétrole si on
regarde le bâtiment si on regarde chez
vous par exemple chez vous la sobriété
c'est quoi c'est de dire de chauffer à
22 21 vous mettez à 20 ou à 19 ça
s'appelle de la sobriété très efficace
vous pouvez aussi habiter dans un
endroit un peu plus petits même si c'est
forcément moi moins drôle déconvenues
sont conformes qu'est ce que c'est
l'efficacité dans le bâtiment
l'efficacité c'est faire
[Musique]
la rénovation thermique donc vous mettez
des vous isolez vos murs avec des choses
de la m d'épaisseur etc ou alors vous
vous isolez vous même avec un pull
s'appelle outils de l'efficacité et ça
coûte un peu moins cher alors comme on
est on approche des périodes des fêtes
je voulais si vous commencez à vouloir
faire des cadeaux et que vous n'avez pas
d'idée vous proposer deux choses on
aurait pu résumer finalement le vous
savez le fameux débat national sur la
transition énergétique qui avait
accouché finalement de la validation de
la promesse de campagne du candidat
hollande ensuite invalidée merci on
aurait pu se dire plutôt vers vélo entre
parenthèses électrique si nécessaire ça
c'est le programme de transition
énergétique pour tous pas cher et vous
pourrez commencer dès noël prochain avec
vos proches ou ou vous même mais la
question qui se pose c'est quand même ou
est ce qu'on les produits ses pulls et
où est ce qu'on les produits ces vélos
qu'est ce qui s'est passé en fait depuis
2004 qu'est ce qu'on a fait en europe on
a pris tout ce qui était dans les pays
rouges et on les a mis dans les pays
vers les gens coûter moins cher il
se trouve que dans ces mêmes pays en
rouge là il était un peu moins rouge ici
est un peu plus rouges deux côté
produits
avec pas mal de charbon donc est ce
qu'on a fait avec notamment l'arrivée
des nouveaux états membres en 2004 eh
bien on a fait de la moins dix ans
social et environnemental on s'est
aligné sur les standards les plus bas je
vous parle pas de la médisance fiscal
bien évidemment et
social environnemental et bien qu'est ce
qu'on va faire demain on va faire de la
mieux disant social et environnemental
et on va plutôt se caler sur les
standards les plus hauts pour une fois
qu'on a dit ça c'est bien beau mais
comment on fait une idée par exemple on
met une taxe carbone sur
la production d'électricité qui va 20
euros la tonne vous sortez le charbon la
production d'électricité le royaume uni
notre fameux pays qui a eu la première
évolution du style elle l'a fait en
quatre ans ils sont passés de 40 % de
production d'électricité à base de
charbon à 2% au premier semestre donc ça
marche sauf que quand vous faites ça
bien évidemment vous vous mettez
d'accord entre 1 7 ans aux pays qui
veulent bien le faire tout le monde sera
pas d'accord pas 195 et après au fond
très à vous mettez une compensation
taxe alors certains vont appeler ça
protectionnisme mais c'est la seule
façon d'y arriver et l'argent que vous
allez pouvoir collecter aux frontières
en fait que vous faites c'est que vous
ne mettez pas dans votre poche vous le
rendez vous le rende et donc aux gens
qui ont produit votre lot vers votre
vélo électrique pour qu'ils puissent
justement sortir plus vite du du charbon
alors qu'est ce qui va se passer demain
ce
qui va se passer demain c'est que dans
un monde contre un an en pétrole on va
avoir moins de choses chacun on le pib
par personne va vraisemblablement
baisser et donc on pourra plus chacun
avoir sa voiture sa
sa perceuse et ce genre de choses et
qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va faire
comme avant c'est dire qu'avant on se
prêtait les choses ont partagé les
choses ce qui veut dire qu'en fait notre
niveau de jeu a pas forcément baisser
dans un d'utilisation mais on aura moins
en moins de choses et la bonne nouvelle
s'écrient est ce que ça va faire c'est
que dans une société actuelle
profondément individualiste et égoïste
vous allez pouvoir créer du lien social
ce qui est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
merci
nicolas pour ce panorama complet il nous
reste deux minutes pour une éventuelle
question oui nos questions
internet qu'est ce que vous voyez que
mix énergétique dont 20 en france
qu'est ce que vous voyez que mix
énergétique dans 20 ans en france alors
déjà on va dire quel est le mix
énergétique aujourd'hui ça n'est pas
100% nucléaire 1 le nucléaire c'est
l'électricité l'électricité c'est la
moitié de l'énergie aujourd'hui en
france et doit être à peu près 30% de
pétrole -1
% de gaz et puis ensuite vous avez du
nucléaire moi je fais partie des gens
qui pensent qu' on n'est pas plus
intelligent tout le monde aujourd'hui on
a 80 % de notre électricité qui
dépend du nucléaire avec des centrales
qui ont dépassé leurs espérances de vie
donc été fait pour fonctionner 30 ans et
l'âge moyen des centrales en france et
un peu plus de 30 ans est-ce que c'est
malin de mettre tous ses oeufs dans le
même panier j'aurais tendance à dire non
et donc comment on fait on va pas les
remplacer par des éoliennes et des
panneaux solaires ça se fait pas comme
ça ce qu'il faut faire c'est réduire
drastiquement notre consommation en fait
quand on parle de mix énergétique
souvent on parle d'offres qu'est ce
qu'on met en face la première chose à
faire c'est de consommer que ce dont on
a besoin que ce soit sur le transport
aujourd'hui avec un vélo électrique ça
vous fait à 10 km et je vous assure vous
arrivez au travail sans transpiration
tout se passe bien il faut limiter au
plus notre utilisation et après voir ce
qu'on met en face si vous baissez votre
consommation d'électricité de 40 % fait
20% d'efficacité 20% de sobriété en fait
vous êtes capable d'arriver à un mix moi
je pense un mix équilibré un peu comme
nos amis anglais qui sont très
pragmatiques peut-être un tiers de
nucléaire un tiers de gaz parce qu'on
aura besoin de gaz naturel pour
compenser la baisse du nucléaire et un
tiers d'énergie renouvelable avec de
l'hydraulique du
de l'éolien du et du dos et du solaire
là on a parlé à l'électricité après sur
le transport effectivement il est grand
temps de réduire au maximum notre notre
consommation de pétrole comme on fait on
peut mettre un truc assez intelligent
qui avait proposé l'ingénieur jean
albert grégoire en 1975 après le premier
choc pétrolier vous mettez une fiscalité
sur non pas des cylindres de la voiture
mais sur son poids voilà donc vous
mettez un prix au kilo de la voiture est
assez vite vous allez avoir des voitures
qui passent plus une tonne 3 pour
déplacer 70 kg mais plutôt 500 kg ça va
être beaucoup plus efficace et on
consommera beaucoup moins de pétrole
l'internet
vous remercie merci beaucoup je suis
désolé il doit y avoir au moins une
vingtaine de questions rentrée mais il
est temps pour nous de conclure juste un
mot avant de vous laisser repartir vous
trouverez dans l'accueil de
l'amphithéâtre un stand pour le bleuet
de france le bleuet de france c'est une
association de solidarité au profit des
victimes et blessés de guerre et leurs
familles mais aussi des victimes
d'attentats civile donc n'hésitez pas à
faire un geste en sortant pour aider
toutes ces familles merci infiniment à
nos conférenciers
[Musique]
et
que nos internautes ne se sentent pas
privé ils peuvent retrouver le bleuet de
france sur internet bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]